ready
that's
uh
1236 today is the
18th
it's you're left-handed too I know I
noticed that yesterday
yeah hey we're the only ones that our
right thank
you
okay good morning everyone today is
Thursday 1: 1824 it's
10ish House Bill 1236 being presented by
representative hunt thank you
representative hunt good morning members
of the committee I'm representative John
Hunt representing ringe and I'm uh like
to say I have great pleasure in bringing
this bill to
you but uh uh because it is a
repeal at least that's what I thought it
was
so um this past year um the uh we have
the new speaker you the speaker had
reelected so they were setting up a
committee uh commissions and we all know
how we want to have less commissions and
do away with commissions and so uh the
request came from me to to who we should
Commerce should be on this commission
and represent the uh from you know and
have to be you know both Republicans and
Democrats you know have to be and I
looked at it and I say no we don't want
no we don't want this commission there
there's no need for this commission and
so therefore I duy put it in my file to
say in September I'll put in a repeal of
this commission and um everything seemed
fine um you know was one of the first
ones in and uh they the department the
legislative Services quickly turned it
around for me and and uh and here here's
the bill now um yes it is true that I
sometimes I legislate on the Fly and not
always always do a lot of homework on
things but you know repealing you know a
commission I thought that would be easy
I wasn't going to think too much about
it um I did know I had a call from Alex
from the insurance department uh
yesterday and I didn't get to the call
um so but this morning
I woke up a little early and I said well
let me let me just look at the you know
think about what I'm was going to say to
you in terms of repealing this
commission so I really to go into the
legislative uh that rsas and it doesn't
exist what do you mean there's no
420j for 4 so 404 excuse me 404 J how
could or 420 I said how could this how
could that be
right and and I said well this you know
there must be a mistake here must be
something you know not right but um so
then I immediately go down to my phone
and take that voicemail from Alex and he
says oh by the way
John that statute doesn't
exist and and you all have I passed out
you you probably don't have it represent
but I've just passed out in front of you
is and then so before
computers before computers if we wanted
to read the
rsas we went over
there okay I remember when I first got
on Commerce I used to drive the chairman
crazy because I would always want to see
what was in the statute because it was
so annoying to look at a bill would just
be like one paragraph a whole section
and I wanted to know what the whole
thing was and he one time he tried to
trip me up because he just got tired of
me kept looking over because I always
wanted to refer to the rsas but anyway
so if you go over to these rsas and they
are dated the books the hard Carvers are
dated and they don't they don't print
them too often can then they have these
supplementals they stick in there so the
this 4 404 J 404 is um is hard cover was
2018 um this commission was created in
20 legislation in
2019 now for those of you who uh do the
math uh 2019 I was not in the Chairman's
chair I was the ranking
minority okay so I knew there there was
that I would want to get rid of this
Commission because it was created while
I was in the minority so there can't be
anything good about this commission but
not withstanding that not withstanding
that I I have no memory really of this
at all okay um I do remember that the
bill um at at the end of the day what I
did find out cuz then so um my I'm
driving in and and I'm trying to find
out what what happened and I decided
that this was a good one for Jim cian
who is our house legal counsel and
fortunately he picked up the phone and I
said Jim can you tell me you know does
this statute exist or not exist or what
happened what I'm told by the insurance
department was that in the bill the way
the bill was written there was a poison
pill and the poison pill Hill was that
some that the department or had to get a
waiver that there had to be there was a
court case and the court case had to
find in favor to allow this miwa model
to to go forward well it turns out the
case died the case failed and so
therefore the statute the law should
never have gone into effect in the first
place so I could then say to you well we
don't need this bill let's just kill it
and let's call it a day could do that
that the problem is is that the
uh as I said there was the Democrats
were in charge so Mr felus former state
senator was the first name and he
actually had a hearing he they actually
used the statute they actually enacted
it they were treating it it was in the
law so theoretically it was in the law
so much to the extent that
even this year where um the speaker
asked me you know to make appointments
everybody assumed the law was there and
I guess there was a period of time that
it was there in the statutes but um the
insurance department told me they had
called the legislative services and said
to him you you might want to get this
thing off the books cuz it's not
supposed to be
there um it I have a call into
legislative services to find out why
they would have me draw up an RS a bill
on a statue that doesn't exist so at
this moment I would normally would say
this just kill the bill and not worry
about it but I I said to to to Jim sansi
I said so you know I called him up and I
says is that of the right plan and I
said or do we need to just pass it and
really put a stake in it so nobody know
we know that this thing doesn't really
exist and he said normally he said no
you probably don't need to do that but I
just saw him when I walked in the door
and he says well maybe you do
because there was an actual hearing on
this legislation so the fact that that
you know if we're you can't expunge an
event that it did occur you know was in
the calendar they had a meeting you know
to expunge that that maybe the best
thing to do would be to pass this so at
this moment um I I I don't know what to
say whether I want to pass this or not
pass it but I just want you to know um
in my 30 some years here I've never had
this happen to me before question and I
had my hand up first I'm more than
welcome to take
questions I brought
Donuts I moveed to remove the
chair uh that motion is out of order
question yes representative okay you may
inquire oh that was bad
so uh uh representative hunt thank you
as people are want to say up here thank
you for your testimony it was most
interesting I can't say though that I
find found it
Illuminating but rather
perplexing and confusing so I'm trying
to understand uh it has been suggested
that we wipe this off the books with
this uh statute
B this bill excuse me this bill even
though it's not in statute because there
was a
hearing because because but the hearing
has no has no force a hearing is a
hearing it it it doesn't carry any
weight in the sense that it it has to be
carried forward with respect to an
action on the proposed legislation
correct so if the proposed
legislation was
sunsetted right because something
happened that made it moot wh why then
do we have to do anything at all I I I
know I'm asking you to explain to me
something that was explained to you well
that's why that's why I had this piece
of paper which you don't have well I I
do I do so what what on this piece of
paper tells me that I have to do what
you okay so that it wasn't effect for 60
days after 60 days it did take effect so
that's why it got stuck in the statutes
so now it's dead but it's gone but the
poison pill case decision occurred later
and so therefore it should have been
removed or should never have been
enacted but
unfortunately um it
did had enough life that the that the
commission did meet so was this excuse
me was was this an action of the
judicial branch that made
this actually actually I'm seeing all
these uh legal opinions here state of
New York versus US Department of Le yeah
this was a federal case all right so
we're just so now what you're saying is
that you're being advised that we should
clean this up legislatively because of
the action that occurred the ruling that
occurred in the courts well I would be
to be frank the advice I'm getting is um
he who knows I mean he he he at this
point even though he's our legal counsel
he he says it whatever way we the
committee decide to do is fine whatever
we do is fine yeah whatever we do is
fine thank you but that that that there
he could C he would his initial instinct
is just kill it but then when he found
out that that that commission met and
actually that the some people treated as
though the law really was in effect then
he's saying maybe P passing the repeal
which you know we Republicans love
repeal so why why not go ahead and
repeal something so repeal nothing fine
than in a vacuum uh rep side of M go
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman let me
try to clarify a little bit at one point
you said the bill had a hearing I think
what you meant was the ill established
commission a hearing thereby giving it
some validity that we need to erase by a
formal repeal which should have happened
automatically which did which that did
not so you don't mean that the bill had
a hearing because that's entirely
irrelevant right the commission was
actually formed Commission in the
between passage and the court case
actually dying the court case didn't
didn't actually have a decision it
actually just went away right I think so
so that's why it's not the bill that had
a hearing the commission met giving it
some legitimacy so would you believe I
think we probably do need to I mean it
sounds like we need to repeal it
actually act on it make a repeal okay
thank you represent bur did you have
you're all said um you just wanted to
get rid of okay thank you Mr
chairman I would say that would be very
difficult to present to the full House
why don't we just withdraw the bill and
make it simple we we unfortunately do
not have that process thank you so yes I
would if we were to pass the Bill of
repeal we would I would assume we would
all put it on you know would put it on
the consent calendar and simply say that
this bill is uh uh is attempt to clean
up the
statutes he thank you um I'm
representative
Gibbs thank you um uh uh you're out of
order representative
Gibbs I just wanted to ask do you have a
recommendation as to what we should do
with this bill yeah I at this point I I
I think um the fact that we we ended
introducing it we ended up doing it then
I think we should just go ahead and just
pass the bill and um and and if the
Senators see it in a different light
then we won't care if they kill it but
but that at this point um I I think a
better part of valor is to just let's
pass it and and clean up the statutes
that makes sense thank you thank you um
I'm going to have an editorial in as
much as I'm the vice chair of the commit
special committee on commissions
representative hunt did exactly what we
would want him to do is to bring forth
legislation to get rid of Bill which
were became law the committee was
established legally and it is now
obsolete so thank you chairman
hunt you're very welcome uh anybody
else HP 1236 is now
closed excuse me Mr uh Mr temporary
chair I I would like to thank uh whoever
was responsible for schu the the bill
order scheduled today to put this first
because things can only get better from
here thank you thank you and I I am not
leaving because if I ever had to report
to my wife what happened when I went to
work today I would not be able to do so
and it would be my
fault
okay uh we'll open up the public Hearing
in House Bill
[Music]
and I will hear
from the sponsor for
merchant good morning representative
Merchant
chairman hunt that is a very difficult
act to
follow hard to follow
this I have some I don't want to read my
testimony I'm sure you folks can read it
as well as I can read it I also have an
amendment to the bill that I'd like to
propose to the committee as well so with
your permission Mr chairman may I pass
out the documents yes
please
so just for clarification Mr chairman I
am really not the sponsor of this bill
although I can speak to it um it was a
bill before I get started um for the
record Mr chairman and also members of
this
committee my name is Gary
Merchant I'm a representative from
district 6 Sullivan
County we're presenting CL Martin
Cen and today I also come to you as the
chair of the prescripture Doug
portability
board so the intent of the bill was that
we have a conflict of interest in the
statute most statues
do the issue that representative Edwards
wanted to address through the bill was
what do you do if you have a conflict
how do you resolve
it so basically at that point in time if
you look at the statute it says that
someone has to declare it but if someone
did not declare it how do you resolve
that conflict
he also had in the bill the word
cohabitation when we had a meeting with
the board on December
18th there was discussion with the board
about the word cohabitation how do you
define it there somebody living with you
for two weeks 3 weeks I mean how do you
basically come up with a definition of
cohabitation representative Edwards was
agreeable at that meeting to strike
those words from the bill which I have
done in the
Amendment the other part of it is that
what do you do when you get to a
conflict and someone basically says
foul how do you resolve it and what I'm
proposing in the amendment is to
basically allow for a two-step
process step one is going to the board
itself and asking the board to weigh in
on the conflict and maybe work with the
individual
about being
recused in talking with Senator abbis he
said that made sense and he said well
what do you do when you have no
resolution between the claimant and the
board so the board says no there's no
conflict but somebody who through the
flag said there's still a conflict and
there was a disagreement there what do
you do and at that point time they said
well you go to an arbitrator and let the
arbitrator decide if they was in fact a
conflict was it done intentionally was
it
unintentional basically understand what
happened so in the amendment I used the
word attorney
general Senator abis didn't like that
because when you start talking about the
attorney general doing a
review it really doesn't look good for
the individual and that's not what we're
trying to get here so we said maybe the
appropriate party is going to be the
attorney on the board so you have an
attorney which is not a board member
it's just somebody on the board
representing the board have them review
it and let them become the arbitrator so
that's kind of what we're trying to get
to here is that a if someone does have a
conflict and someone wants to file a
violation there's a process and the
process basically comes down to you go
to the board in non-public session and
you have a discussion and let the board
make the first cut at it to determine
whether there's a conflict or not
if there's still not agreement between
the parties you go to an arbitrator
which would be the board's
attorney and let them decide
it once there's been a
ruling that the individual did in fact
have a conflict which is not
disclosed then you could remove the
person when that person gets
removed we believe that the person to
replace that individual was the party or
the entity that appointed them in the
first place
so basically if it's
a person appointed by the Speaker of the
House you go back to the speaker and you
ask for him or her to appoint a new
person for the length of the term
remaining if it's a Senate President you
go back to the Senate if it's the
governor you go back to the governor so
basically that's the process we're
trying to work on here with the bill and
also with the
amendment so in saying that I'll leave
it for questions from the committee to
what we're trying to do I think
fundamentally is that representative
Edwards which the board agrees with that
there should be some process in place to
deal with a conflict of interest that
somebody thinks was not
disclosed okay so both Senator abis
excuse me Senator abis and and
representative Edwards know about this
amendment yes I talked to Senator abis
last night he's the one that um provided
some guidance and he talked about the
same thing about the concern of using
the word attorney general because it's
kind of honorous I mean nobody wants to
have on the record that you went through
the attorney general for a review it's
not something you really want to have
out there but it should be done by
somebody who has a legal background and
the board attorney because they're not a
board member but they're there to advise
the board would be the appropriate
person to go to okay so that's the
conflict identified by the Attorney
General but I would change attorney
general to board's attorney oh you you
want to have that changed yes board
attorney and I will be more than glad to
another amendment okay I'll make another
amendment now hence my my confusion okay
question about that yeah so you thank
you representative Terry uh I'm
wondering if you can disabuse me of the
notion that by identifying the attorney
to the
board you're still not as an
arbitrator you're still not waiting in
the in favor of the board would not the
attorney to the board could not and
would not the the board's attorney be
consulted anyway and even if the
attorney were to be consulted
nevertheless the attorney is the
attorney of the board and not a true
neutral third party I understand this is
difficult but I'm not sure that this is
the a good fix can you disabuse me of
that that notion um I think I here we
get concern is that is the attorney for
the board truly a neutral
party and in essence I would say as an
attorney I would hope that their ethics
would be what's driving their decision
not because they happen to be connected
to the board um I'm not opposed to
trying to come up with another form of
arbitration but I'm trying to be sure
that it goes through sort of a legal
review and not through a political
review well for the question me inquire
so I would urge you to do that because
the perception here is not a good one uh
in my view I'm trying to put myself in a
in in this kind of a situation and I'm
looking for a neutral third-party
arbitrator and I'm not seeing that I'm
seeing somebody who is actually related
to one of the parties that are in the
dispute so thank you if representative
Terry if I may um if you have some
recommendations by all means I'd be more
than glad to or the committee could I
mean I hear are you the
concern we it will have a subcommittee
anyways but yeah we we need to find
something before the you know
subcomittee okay represented
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman uh just um
for
clarification
uh in the bill uh sorry in the amendment
uh that you've provided it says that
attorney general so what you're
proposing is to change attorney general
wherever it says that to to board
attorney correct thank you uh further
question may
inquire further question may inquire
thank you
uh has any conflict of interest ever
actually occurred on the prescription
drug app affordability board no not to
my knowledge there was a board member
initially on the board
that the individual some people felt
that the person had a conflict and that
person was removed from the board thank
you yeah I'm sorry about my pause there
because I actually wrote something down
differently I wrote because it says
identified by the Attorney General so I
said ident identified by the attorney
appointed by the attorney general that
works okay so that way a we made sure
that you know the attorney and this and
that the the one that is appointed by
the I I think if we have that language
in there hun chairman um an attorney
appointed by the Attorney General's
office I think that's probably a
reasonable way to go right and so it
yeah okay
L I'm looking at the
amendment and I was looking on page two
yeah and I'm looking at line three
correct I think it works
l so down to 18 or 19
disclosure
remember shall be reviewed by the New
Hampshire attorney
general I think we're trying to get to
be consistent we be attorney appointed
by the Attorney
General okay yeah okay yeah okay that
makes
sense
okay all right we were looking at two
different
places okay good yes represented pelli
thank you for letting me ask the
question we have many different boards
commissions Etc uh is there already an
existing conflict of interest policy
that you've been able to discover so
that we're not trying to reinvent the
wheel that's a very good question I
can't speak to the other boards um
the issue of what do you do to resolve a
conflict is what we're addressing here
with this board but I think that issue
that we're talking about maybe gerain to
other boards as
well for the question may inquire well I
just wanted to be consistent so if there
already is a policy in place with other
uh boards and commissions I would just
ask that we be
consistent good that I can't speak to
because I really don't have the
knowledge but it's a good
point yeah
um I mean if I can clarify would it be
nice to yeah if we could refer to an RSA
that's already on the books correct yeah
okay I I'll have our researcher I'll
have our researcher look that up yeah
okay do we Mr chairman I mean part of it
too be do we have something even in our
house um rsas that drive us because we
can have conflicts what do we do when we
have a conflict how do we resolve it I
mean that's what trying to get to well
we do we we have the conflict of the uh
yeah the yeah what is the committee I'm
spacing out what it's called right now
ethics the Ethics Committee yeah it
would go to
ethics but that's only for
legislators so not
pareses but I guess yeah the boards yeah
research okay
okay I'll have her research she's not
here today because she's has other
committees okay anybody
else all right thank
you okay
yeah so R grassy you're tag you're it uh
check the blue she whenever before I
close the
hearing uh just see if there's any so I
why don't you check the first two bills
we've done so
far okay
perfect you get it right and get the
third one
around
generic
Biologicals
put's okay we'll open up the public
hearing on
1365 and this time we will hear from the
prime
sponsor representative Merchant thank
you Mr chairman and also thank you for
the members of the committee for the
record my name is Gary Merchant um
Sullivan County district 6 the prime
sponsor of the bill also I still remain
the chair of the prescription dou for
Ability board the last I knew as of 10
minutes ago so what I'm trying to do
today this is maybe one of those rare
moments in
life in
which both parties come together over
the principle of
premarket and fundamentally if you think
about where we have come with generics
today and the ability to contain
cost the use of generics has been
phenomenally successful
it has created a tremendous amount of
savings both for the patient insurance
companies and so
forth to give you an
example if you look at the L latest
latest edition of the insurance
department
report of
2021 biologics now account for over 50%
of the drug spend 50% of the drug
spent last year according to their data
they went up 14
.5% generics went down
25% and that's because of a free market
when you have competition in the
marketplace it does what it's supposed
to do the Invisible Hand of the
market through competition brings
product price
down and what I'm trying to do with this
bill is do the same thing in biologics
that we have done with traditional
generics now you're going to hear about
the fact that biologics are not 100%
interchangeable and I
concur however the FDA goes through
switching studies which basically
means that they take patients and they
put them on drug a and then switch them
over to drug B they know that clinically
they work the same but the concern is
the risk factor can you actually change
between one biologic with the other one
and not cause harm to the
patient if the FDA says they're
interchangeable therefore the risk to
the patient harm wise has been
neutralized because through the studies
switching back and forth that is what
happens however the FDA is silent in
this whole process and what I'm trying
to get to in the state of New Hampshire
with free or die is to bring the
principle the free market to biologics
and on the back of this
testimony is a very simple
diagram what I'm basically saying same
thing the FDA is saying is that if drug
aera is equal to drug B and Drug a is
equal to drug
C
therefore b equals c they're
interchangeable it's the same thing that
happens with traditional generics a
generic manufacturer does not have to
show
bio availability equivalency between
another generic manufacturer only with
the reference product they only have to
go back and say my drug is equal as a
therefore if you're in the bucket of
interchangeability all drugs that are
interchangeable are themselves
interchangeable because they've gone
through the scrutiny of the FDA and what
I'm trying to advocate for here in New
Hampshire is to allow for greater
flexibility greater competition so that
we can make drugs more
affordable to the patient to the
insurance companies and start working on
the escalating cost of biologics to give
you an example male
clinic spent over $107
million they went through something
comparable in the first year alone they
saved over $20
million is almost a 20% decrease
subsequent years it gets less because
you don't have the opportunity to save
more money M because you do a lot of it
in the first year so all this bill
fundamentally does is allow for that
flexibility in the marketplace to open
up competition by the way in
Europe this only deals with drugs the
FDA considers to be interchangeable with
each other in Europe through 20 years of
History if you have a bio similar
there's no requirement to do switching
studies it's just basically that point
in time if you look at the cost of their
biologics compared to ours it's
dramatically different why because they
have more competition than we do here in
the United States so it becomes a
barrier to competition I'm trying to
minimize and trying
to erase if you will so that the market
can for perform the way it supposed to
perform so that's the intent of the bill
it's pretty simple a equals B A equals c
therefore b equals C thank you
Mr
chairman repres
senary uh I think I would like some
clarification on the terms biosimilar
and
equal
because equal to me means the same
biosim a similar means like in
presumably since this is a drug in terms
of its shall we be kind and say benefit
has the same effect
so you have two drugs that have the same
effect even though they're not the same
therefore they're not truly equal in the
sense that 3 equals 3 2 equals 2 because
two is two so 2 equals 2 right so
they're not they're not they're
equivalent in terms of their
effect but they're not equivalent
because they actually have
different names so they're they're not
exactly the same and that's the reason
why they're generic instead
of uh what's the term for the original
brand name right am I am I getting this
yes and no um how about the how about
the yes part first okay sure the yes
part is that when we deal with biologics
when you deal with traditional what they
call small molecules they are in fact a
chemical which you can duplicate
identically now just to understand
within the generic Market
when you have a generic it's not
identical to another generic the active
ingredient is but the fillers the
binders and everything else that goes
into the tablet are different so they're
not identical to each other the active
ingredient is identical but the compound
itself collectively is
not so it's it's like by analogy it's
like a different packaging it's putting
the same product in a different package
well you're saying the filler when you
when you when you make a tablet the
amount of active ingredient a lot of
times it's say 40 milligrams yeah is the
size of maybe top of a pin head it's
small right so you can't possibly put
that into a formulation so what you do
is you put lactose with it you put other
ingredients to make the tablet large
enough the person to handle it also the
way it works within the body if you want
it to dissolve you have what they call
binders and things that go into it and
those things are not regulated by the
FDA so therefore what the manufacturer
has to do is show that their formulation
of the generic product does in fact work
the same way in the body that the brand
name does right yeah I'm sorry I I think
I misled you using the term
packaging um you've
explained the need for the fillers
because the 40 milligrams or whatever is
so small you you you you couldn't even
find it in the vi when you're taking it
sorry so what you have with generics is
you have different fillers all right but
you're it's it's essentially the same
drug so when a generic comes along a
generic is the same is is the same has
the same drug so to speak but it would
have different binders and fillers and
that's what makes for generic it it it
has the same active ingredient active
ingredient but the inactive ingredients
are different okay
all right thank uh real quickly uh
representative Gibbs would would you go
please thank you uh just to be sure I
understand um is it correct that the the
diagram you handed out shows the
situation as it is today and that's what
you're trying to change correct today
basically if you look at the FDA what
goes on in the
marketplace the switching studies which
shows again that you can switch the
products between each other with minimal
risk to the patient they work clinically
the same that is back to like same thing
with generics you drug B has been shown
to be equal to drug a drug C has been
equal to drug a what I'm saying is the
same thing with generics B is equal to C
there's no risk basically to the patient
it's gone again it's gone through a
tremendous amount of studies with
patients they basically have to go
through the process is take patients on
drug a switch them over to B
take drug B switch them back to a so
they can show that there is no risk to
the patient when the change occurs the
further question so today you cannot
switch from drug B to drug C but you
want to make it so that you can switch
from B to C because of the equivalence
with a correct I'm trying to allow for
the market so to instead of the
pharmacist if you write for drug B I
only can give you a so to give you an
idea herera cost about $3,300 a
month drug B cost about $1,200 a month
drug C cost less than $600 a month so if
I sit there as a pharmacist and if you
write for drug B at 1,200 I can't give
you the one drug C for 600 because I
don't have the authority to make that
change and what I'm saying is by
allowing all three to be considered
interchangeable with each
other as a pharmacist working with the
patient I can then therefore work with
the patient to say well you don't need
to buy a $1,200 drug there's one here
for
600 that FDA shown that they're equal to
the brand name and we can save you a
significant amount of money $1,200
versus 600 that's $7,000 a year folks Mr
chairman Mr wait question you're also
okay represent m one has a question
thank you Mr chairman and sorry I'm a
little bit rushed I've got to introduce
a bill 11 um so the one thing that we're
not talking about here is truly the
different types of
biologics identicals and similars that's
the term neither of them are in the bill
right those are the terms that influence
what's prescribed what's therapeutically
effective and what's paid for and and
that's why it's in this committee
because this is fundamentally a payer
payer issue at at the potential expense
of therapeutic benefit right so we have
to talk about and I I'll invite you to
talk a little bit about if I'm assuming
you're familiar the definitions of
biological similar and a biological
identical right everyone here
understands generic pyc versus you know
uh whatever all the different those
generics but in the small molecule large
molecule
world the the likelihood of protein
sugars attaching to proteins differently
uh all the immunogenicity problems
there's there's sign ific issues and
that's why they're defined as either
biological similars or identicals and we
have some work to do in subcommittee but
if you can talk about those issues
that'd be great first of all there's no
such thing as a biological identical it
doesn't exist it's Nature Made and
therefore even within the same brand
name trade name if I may from one batch
to the next they're not
identical because exactly okay so
therefore even within the brand name you
don't have things that are identical
just like do with chemicals between one
manufacturer another the active
ingredient is identical but the inactive
ingredients may not the same thing here
when you talk about a
biosimilar it works clinically the same
that's why you have switching studies to
show that you can change from one drug
to the other without risk to the patient
that's why the FDA forces that switching
study further
question I thought you were hurrying up
till 11 o' for for for example even if
they have the same peptide chain it's
known that they may not have the same
therapeutic effect right they may they
might may just be delivered different
differently anyways I think it's subit
it's okay we'll go to subcommittee I
think what I'm saying simple question
yeah okay now representa
Terry so as an insurance subcommittee
member at an insurance subcommittee
hearing today um and and unlike a former
speaker of the United States house I do
feel the responsibility to understand
the bill before I passed the bill I
would I I I am perplexed here
um and I think the best way for me to
ask the question is if the I I recall
that when a prescription in the old days
would be filed on on paper and I would
take it to the pharmacist it would say
generic sub substitution permitted so if
we were in that kind of a situation and
my doctor prescribed Huma but generic
substitution was permitted then you as
the pharmacist if you don't mind my
personalizing this you could substitute
drug b or the Lesser expensive drug C
right but if the doctor prescribed drug
B which is a generic then you could
and and allow generic substitution there
is no generic because it is a generic
then you would not be able to provide me
with drug C because the doctor had
prescribed drug B is that is that corre
I'm trying to get at this from the
standpoint
of brand named drug generic substitute
permitted you can give me drug C because
it costs less than drug B right you can
do that but if the doctor prescribes
drug b or drug C you cannot prescribe
drug C or drug B the substitute for C or
B correct okay and what I'm trying to
get to here is that when you have a
prescription just like you do with
generics if the pro provider the
prescriber writes on the prescription
medically necessary dispense is written
I have no authority to change that
prescription without your approval so if
a doctor really feels that they don't
want to have any substitution at all
then at that point in time I'm Bound by
that limitation okay follow for question
me
thank so to your uh to your comment
earlier or to to your uh remark earlier
that a generic would be
biosimilar to the brand name drug am I
okay so I go to my eye doctor recently
and I have dry eye and we're talking
about rasis and then we're talking about
cyclo something or other which is a
generic and she
says we don't want to give you the
generic because it's no good it doesn't
work as well as Restasis so I'm trying
to understand how can a generic which is
supposed to be biosimilar be classified
by a provider is no good compared to the
brand named drug unless the provider is
carrying water for
the yeah can you can you help me with
that one well that because that that
does bear on this bill what what need
what we have to go back to we should go
back to is what I call the orange book
of substitutability the FDA goes through
studies to show that a generic is
substitutable for the brand and it's
given what they call an AB rated which
means at that point in time it's
substitutable some drugs and this could
be the case with stasis it's B rated not
a rated so therefore the FDA is saying
we don't have enough data to support The
Interchange and as a pharmacist if it's
not a rated which means it's been
approved by the FDA for
interchangeability I can do it but if
it's B I
can't so the FDA is calling the shots if
the FDA says it's a b-rated product as a
pharmacist I cannot do The Interchange
without the provider status if it's
a-rated
the FDA says they're interchangeable
then I
can quick file therefore yes sir do you
give me permission yes yeah then I'll
yield back the balance of my
time so I wish we we need to be a little
light here so uh so what happened in
this instance was the provider actually
prescribed B the generic and then a year
later told me it it's junk and I'm not
you know I'm not going to prescribe this
any longer we're going to go back to a
or you'll have to do something else okay
but the
pharmacist it has to distinguish between
a and b and can only substitute if
generic is permitted if it's a corre
classified rather than b correct and
it's the same thing I'm trying to get to
here with this diagram is that when this
the FDA goes through the
interchangeability studies it's saying
that they have documentation that it's
safe for the patient they work the same
exactly and these are both A's all these
what I'm saying is they all are
considered A's what I want to be clear
in our state law that we consider them
in the state of New Hampshire all
equivalent and therefore a pharmacist
can have the ability of using the
marketplace to give the patient the
lowest cost drug available to them so
instead of buying a $1,200 drug which is
a generic they could actually buy the
$600 one thank you and I do you
back um so I was kind of scratching my
head to figure out why this bill's here
rather than than that uh Health and
Human Serv a different committee but I
just noticed there the key
words medically necessary cor right
that's that's our possession that's not
hhs's that's that's us right so the only
thing I would
be somewhat I guess thinking that I want
to make sure I do this is that when a
pharmacist makes this recommendation go
with other is that it really does save
money that the the recommendation is
based on a
monetary value other other than than you
know because you've said that several
times in your testimony that in one
there's a cheaper one I guess I thinking
I might want to have write that into
this this bill M chairman hun if that's
what it takes to get the bill through
the committee that's fine I I think um
pharmacist in general that's an advocate
for the patient is trying to find out
how to make drug therapy more affordable
right but if you want to insert that
that's fine just also I just got a text
from the
um um the chair of the prescription
sorry the chair of the New Hampshire
pharmacist Association and also the um
chair of the pharmacy board the pharmacy
board voted unanimously yesterday to
support the bill great I have a question
or just uh okay represent Herber thank
you um just just for the record uh I
can't be seen I have a family member
that uh takes a
thyroid uh medicine and uh it was called
armor by shorthand was armor I think it
had something to do with a pig yeah it
did it did and and uh and and
uh somebody came up with a synthetic
generic and uh didn't work for my family
member but on the armor uh drug was
taken off the
market it was so so what what we did is
we went to a pharmacist who can could
make the uh
compound uh on his own but the insurance
was gone it wasn't going to pay for it
and fortunately it's not a fortune to uh
do but I that is a circumstance that you
might have the uh the cost cutting
actually bump a
uh uh a superior product for a number of
people off the uh off the shelf and in
that case you're insurance they won't
pay for it
so in that case it wasn't cost
effective well when there's always
exception there's always exceptions to
everything I hear what you're saying
about armor it was a great product but
un unfortunately and it's right it was
taken from the thyroids from uh animals
if you will and it was a natural product
but unfortunately the FDA said you have
to go through and show studies that it's
effective so the company said we can't
afford to pay for all the studies
because the margin on the product is so
small there's no return on the
investment so they basically did away
with
it representative melier has a question
yes I do thank you Mr chairman thank you
Carrie oh oh sorry about that quick
question has has this legislation or
similar legislation um been enacted or
proposed in any other states that you
know
of I'm not aware of it I mean I can do
some research I talk to the industry and
so forth about it
um but I can do some research to find
out and so forth that would be I mean
I'm also working with the trade
associations tentatively they're coming
out in support of the bill but they want
to be sure that goes to the biosimilar
um Committee in order to sign off on it
but the initial pass on it is that
they're in support of of it um correct
well look forward to hearing from you
when we do the subcommittee thank you
okay having no more questions thank you
very much is there anyone else who would
like to testify on this
bill okay seeing none we will close the
public hearing
um representative Merchant did you fill
out a second card for this
one I believe yeah on both bills oh I
see this one actually was 1225 you never
did one for
1236 no no you just you testified you
were the one
who and therefore you fill out a paint
card when you do
that
sorry
um so this is uh
Jason
you have to push the button and hold the
mic close for the record Jason AES
director of Health economics insurance
department okay so uh the reason why I'm
asking you because I know the department
doesn't take uh positions on what I
would call mandates the question I have
is that um I knew under the Affordable
Care Act there was limitations upon um
any new health insurance mandates so I
was just wondering whether you know
whether or not whether this bill falls
into that category yes if this bill in
its current form if it were enacted
would be subject to the cost of frail um
the the federal cost defa defrayal for
the exchange Marketplace why don't you
explain that to the committee what that
cost consequence is there's a federal
law rule that states that if we man if a
state mandates coverage that goes beyond
what's referred to as essential health
benefits which is defined by our S
silver plan in New Hampshire then the
state would be responsible for paying
any additional cost that that occurs and
this legislation would would qualify as
that uh in addition to that this um Bill
if if it were passed would be subject to
um referral to the insurance department
for a mandate study to to estimate the
economic cost and the social cost of
this new
legislation perfect thank you thank you
very much okay now so the
[Music]
sponsor yeah here he is okay repres
Dave good morning good
morning for the record I'm
representative hope Damon Sullivan
District 8 um boogieing in here from
House Education committee it's a little
calmer in here at the moment
um I represent Sullivan District 8 which
is a nin toown ferial it serves the
beautiful Sugar River communities of
aworth Goan Langdon lemster Springfield
sopy Washington my hometown of Cen and
the City of
Claremont I retired from a 43-year
rewarding career as a dietitian and
diabetes educator a year ago my
experience is helping people with
diabetes for decades are what inspired
me to bring this bill forward House Bill
1571 15
1971 which I'd also like to call the
diabetes device affordability act seeks
to require commercial insurers and
Medicaid to cover glucose monitoring
devices and the necessary supplies for
all people with
diabetes not being sure how much folks
on this committee know about diabetes
I'm going to ask you to bear with me
while I give you a brief 101 of diabetes
so it'll help you understand why this is
important diabetes is a common condition
that increases the risk of complications
such as heart disease stroke kidney
failure blindness or amputation of a
lower limb it is the seventh leading
cause of death in the US controlling
blood sugars well dramatically reduces
the risk of these complications as well
as improving quality of
life
98,500 people in New Hampshire are
currently diagnosed with diabetes that's
just under 9% of our
population there are 6,600 new cases
diagnosed each year in New Hampshire
29,000 New Hampshire people have
diabetes and don't know it and in
additional whopping 351,000 people in
New Hampshire or just under 33% of our
population have pre-diabetes meaning
their blood gluc levels are above normal
but not high enough to diagnose diabetes
and they're vulnerable to developing
diabetes so we all know someone probably
more than one person with diabetes
diabetes is expensive
in 2017 the most recent data I found
there were $944 million in direct
medical costs for treating diabetes in
New Hampshire and $319 million in
indirect costs attributed to diabetes
people with diabetes spend about 2.3
times more on medical expenses than
those without
diabetes so glucose monitoring and
glucose is just the medical word for
sugar blood sugar provides Insight on
the impact of all all the choices people
make that affect their blood sugars
their food intake their physical
activity
medications there are actually about 25
variables that affect blood sugars and
blood sugars vary throughout the day so
the only way for a person with diabetes
to really know how they're doing and
taking care of their condition is to get
data to check their blood
sugar blood sugar checks are useful in
the morning or or whenever somebody has
had their longest sleep when they're
fasting which is often their lowest
blood sugar but not always it's useful
prior to meals and snacks to know if
you're high before a meal you might
choose to eat differently than if you're
moderate before a meal you might
medicate
differently um similarly you might check
after meals to see how you did did you
make the right judgment can you learn
from that for the next time
around at bedtime to be safe going into
hours of sleep in the middle of the
night for some people with diabetes is
necessary prior to during and after
exercise for the most part exercise
lowers blood sugar but not always in
everybody it's not completely
predictable um monitoring is useful when
low blood sugar is suspected and after
treating low bluc blood glucose levels
to make sure they've normalized it's
useful when you think you could be high
you cannot always tell by symptoms in
fact the longer you have diabetes the
less likely that you can tell that
you're dropping high or low by how you
feel that
is and it's useful prior to performing
critical tasks such as driving driving
when your blood sugar is low makes you
behave like your DWI in fact people have
been pulled over and law enforcement
thought that they were under the
influence when in fact the reality was
there a person with diabetes whose blood
sugar was too low for them to be safely
driving which could happen rapidly they
could have been okay when they got
behind the
wheel so glucose monitoring is an
integral component of effective therapy
trying to treat diabetes without glucose
monitoring is like driving without a
speedometer you simply don't know your
status the frequency of glucose
monitoring is individualized it depends
on how that person's diabetes is being
treated how vulnerable they are to
unexpected low blood sugars whether
there is a concurrent illness going on
that could be affecting blood sugars the
age of the individual how long they've
had diabetes there's a there's a lot of
variables that would dictate how
frequently a person would be recommended
to monitor their
sugars so it could be anywhere from
somebody who's very stable with their
diabetes might be checking their sugar
once a day to a person with a lot of
variability in their blood sugars or a
lot of variability in their
lifestyle they might be checking sugar
12 15 times a day to be
safe there are two approaches to blood
sugar monitoring commonly people prick
their finger to get a tiny drop of blood
it's applied to a test strip which is
then inserted into a glucometer to read
the results takes about 30 seconds test
strips are single use only that's
important as I said people might test
once a day or many times um even people
who are very knowledgeable about
managing their diabetes need monitoring
to be sure of what is going on it is
common for only a limited number of test
strips to be covered by Medicare and
Commercial insurers to use an old cliche
that is Pennywise and pound foolish
there are mechanisms for people to get
more test strips prescribed but it's
kind of a jumping through hoops Rodeo
for someone who has a challenging
condition that takes a lot of their time
and energy to effectively address to
also have to keep
documenting and getting a new script
from their provider to authorize the
insurer to provide them an adequate
number of test strips it makes people
give up on bothering to test as often as
they ideally would it's just another
barrier in a complicated
scenario as you might expect pricking
your finger multiple times daily isn't a
particularly pleasant experience
although I will say G comers have
improved enormously from when I started
my career as a dietitian in
1979 the drop of blood is in fact tiny
the lanets are much narrower and I say
this in part for the public listening to
encourage people not to be intimidated
from doing that but it is still you're
you're perking your finger the TV
advertising notwithstanding we do not
have a way to test blood sugar that is
non-invasive it doesn't exist
yet so dealing with blood and a little
bit of pain but a little bit of pain
multiplied times many episodes of that
makes it hard for people to check as
frequently as would be beneficial
continuous glucose monitoring is a
wonderful alternative a CGM is a device
for measuring glucose levels continually
through a sensor that you wear and it
slightly penetrates your skin when
applied they're about the size of a dime
maybe a little bigger they are designed
to remain in place for at least 7even
days depending on the particular product
it may be 10 days
real-time cgms send and display blood
sugars to a smartphone or receiver
automatically they really help people
understand the effects of their
lifestyle on blood sugar while I was
still practicing I was frequently
impressed by the considerable increase
in understanding of diabetes when people
began using
CGM cgms are not new but they have not
been in the common lexicon for people to
use for diabetes until the last several
years near the end of my time in
practice one of the companies had a
program where you could get a sample CGM
unit it would only work for I don't
remember now I think it was 10 days um
so that people could test out what it
would be like to wear a CGM and what
kind of information they would get from
it it was such a pleasure as a provider
trying to help people take good care of
themselves to have this opportunity for
people to try it out and see how much
they would
learn and I so clearly remember the
first person who sampled this working
with me and and many
following she was a woman in her
50s she really worked hard to take good
care of her diabetes before the CGM but
it frankly wasn't going very well her
numbers were too high she was at risk
and she came in after that trial period
with the CGM and literally was euphoric
she said to me I have never understood
my d diabetes the way I understand it
now I want one of these forever and her
insurance company denied her
coverage because many insurance
companies will only cover cgms if the
patient needs to take insulin and this
woman was not being treated with insulin
and we could not get them to
budge uh lost my place here oh yes so
also cgms provide Trend info meaning
they indicate to the patient whether
their blood sugar is trending up or down
that is very helpful information in
making decisions about how much
medication you might take or whether to
take medication or should you have a
snack before you go out and do a run so
that your blood sugar doesn't go too low
you get the idea of where things are
going not just what the point in time
number
is in fact one of my colleagues on the
house education committee which I hope
is going to break away I just realized I
was to remind him to come here wears a
continuous glucose monitor and we
occasionally hear it beep as he is
alerted of the trend of what is
happening with his blood sugar diabetes
is a balancing act trying to prevent
harmful high blood sugars while avoiding
overcorrecting and getting dangerously
low blood sugars CGM is associated with
lower average blood sugars while
preventing unsafe flows less risk of
complications and fewer
hospitalizations people who have
asymptomatic hypoglycemia or nighttime
hypoglycemia that's low blood sugar are
much safer with CGM up to 75% of high
and low blood sugars go undetected
without CGM people don't know where
they're at because you simply aren't
going to prick your finger every five
minutes all day long even if you had an
unlimited Supply test strips no one
would do that all of the improvements
associated with using a CGM are reversed
if the CGM is discontinued which happens
all too frequently if if a patient
changes coverage people need continued
access regardless of age A1C level or
form of
treatment I'm going to skip over the
next part here but you'll see in my
written
testimony um the recommendations from
American Diabetes Association standards
of care which were just updated this
month and the confirmation from the
endocrine Society American Association
of di of diabetes Educators and American
Association of Cl cl cl chronologists
all supporting what I am saying and I
will go to the edited version of the
bill because as you've seen the bill is
long um it's a little bit duplicatus
because the first half is about
commercial insurance and the second half
is about Medicaid coverage they're
almost exactly the same it's just needed
to be put into statute for both um the
same language so the summary of the
bill all continuous or traditional blood
cgos monitors and the necessary supplies
for any person with a diagnosis of
diabetes of any kind including Type 1
Diabetes Type 2 diabetes gestational
diabetes which is diabetes during
pregnancy or any other type of diabetes
or
hypoglycemia would be covered supplies
include but are not limited to sensors
test strips the lanets to prick your
finger alcohol wipes which you
need the bill would require coverage be
provided without regard to the form of
treatment we now have a wide array of
medications in the toolbox for diabetes
some are oral medications some are
injectable but are not
insulin and then there are a variety of
different kinds of insulin that have
different durations of
action the
right treatment for a patient is the one
that gets them good blood sugar control
it's not one is preferable to another in
a broad stroke way so when our insurers
or Medicaid tie the availability of
glucose monitoring to one form of
treatment they're putting providers in
the position of saying well maybe we
should start you on insulin so you can
adequately monitor your bread sugars
when maybe insulin isn't the best way
for that person to be treating their
diabetes so I don't think that the
coverage should be tied to the form of
treatment
to qualify for continued coverage under
this RSA the recipient would need to
participate in follow-up care with their
treating licensed Healthcare
practitioner in person or through telea
Health at least once every 6 months
during the first 18 months of the
glucose monitoring to assess the
efficacy of using the monitor for
treatment of his or her diabetes and
then after the first 18 months follow-up
care occurring a minimum of once every
12 months which is the standard of care
for diabetes anyway upon approval of new
or improved glucose monitoring devices
and Supplies by the Food and Drug
Administration all policies governed by
this section shall guarantee coverage of
new diabetes equipment and supplies when
medically appropriate and prescribed by
a licensed healthc care practitioner
qualified to treat diabetes that section
is from Rhode Island statute it is in
place and the intent of it is diabetes
research is substantial and ongoing and
we are evolving in the technology the
idea of that would be that we would not
have to come back to statute and say oh
now we have something better than the
CGM that was in existence when the
statute was created that we would simply
be able to respect the
state-of-the-art and authorize that
coverage and
Care uh let's see and then
finally uh beginning
on proposed anyway July 1st 2024
coverage for gluc post monitoring
equipment and supplies shall have a
limit on the total amount that an
insured is required to pay for a 30-day
supply of all medically necessary
covered di diabetes devices that are in
accordance with their treatment plan at
an amount not to exceed $30 so a $30
co-pay these devices shall be covered
without being subject to a deductible
and any cost sharing paid by an insured
shall be applied toward the insured's
deductible obligation nothing in this
section prevents an insurer from
reducing an insured co-payment or co-
insurance without coverage cgms are in
the vicinity of $500 a month that is a
whopping sum of money especially added
to the other costs of treating
diabetes I'm going to pause here there
are other speakers who will provide you
more input and detail but I am happy to
try to answer questions if I can and I
thank you very much for your interest
and attention representative
Speer so you listed a um how much money
diabetes is costing us in general and
it's pretty high but if a person keeps
and I'm I'm I don't know anything too
much about diabetes but if a person
keeps their blood sugar nice and steady
can they expect to avoid a lot of the
illnesses you talked about heart disease
and kidney
failure so keeping it steady is very
very critical to avoiding much worse
situ situations thank you for the
excellent question and yes we have known
since the I don't remember when this
study was I was in practice a long time
I want to say the late
80s that if you strictly control blood
sugar and so you have the greatest
amount of what is called time in range
so blood sugar is not a pinpoint it's a
range and if you are able to keep a
person's blood sugar in range most of
the time which is a lot really can't do
it without glucose monitoring we can
largely eliminate
complications there should be no reason
why any person diagnosed with diabetes
today and effectively treating it would
have an amputation or kidney
failure heart disease has a lot of
variables diabetes is the number one
cause of heart disease I'm not going to
guarantee I'm going to guarantee
anything but I don't think we would
eliminate heart disease but we would
greatly greatly reduce it so yes
representative spear the costs of
diabetes are very much related to how
well it's taken care
of represent
Gibbs thank you Mr chairman um I'm going
to ask a question that is based on what
was told me a long time ago by a friend
with type 1 diabetes um and I'm not sure
that I understood correctly at the time
which is why I'm going to ask you this
question is there a device which
combines continuous glucose monitoring
with um uh timed or continuous relief
release of insulin into the bloodstream
when it's
needed that's an excellent question
thank you so if anybody behind me wants
to update me because as noted I'm no
longer in practice I think that device
is still only available in a research
context so there are insulin pumps which
provide the part of Representative Gibbs
question of dispensing insulin they're
programmable they're enormously
flexible that's a whole other topic in
legislation perhaps for another day um
and there are continuous glucose
monitoring devices a closed loop system
would put those two together I know that
there has been research at Mass General
and they trial them um well not to
conflict me isn't this the invention
Dean Cayman right I don't know and I
should obviously so so yes this product
is available and in is it out there in
the marketplace
yes wow cool I stand
corrected thank you represent
hunt I'm the last person in the will be
telling you this but but yes uh it's
okay all
right further question further question
may inquire
um if uh well apparently the the that um
device is now out in the
market if it is uh assuming that it is
would it be covered under this
bill there is no language in this bill
to address that
device I would think we would want to
put language in to prevent any
ambiguity but send
my interpretation would be that device
is a continuous glucose monitor it
happens to also be an insulin pump so I
would say yes so but but but based on
your testimony and again whether I was
paying attention or not your issue here
is not for those people who are have
diabetes and and we getting insulin
tested your issue here is that the
insurance companies are not reimbursing
for the test kits if the person doesn't
need insulin is that correct thank you
for the question to
clarify that is part of the intent of
this bill okay so all people with
diabetes regardless of whether they're
treated with insulin but certainly
including folks who are treated with
insulin should have access to the
glucose monitoring devices that work
well for them okay and I should just
note if you have a continuous glucose
monitor you also need to have a
traditional glucose monitor because
there are occasional circumstances that
I'm sure you don't want me to get in the
Weeds about that you would need to use
your traditional monitor as a backup to
the CGM got it okay next is I think
representa MCU and then represent Terry
thank you Mr chairman thanks for
bringing this important topic to us and
I respect all your work as a diabetic
educator that's tough work and great
work um you probably remember the leango
model of surrounding those potential
diabetic patients with the best-in-class
customer service and just sending anyone
even remotely close to a 5.8 or whatever
A1C uh a glucose monitor and it worked
wonderfully and they did it because they
knew the health economics were solid the
payers knew that if we bought all these
send them out sent them out that it
would lower their bottom line elsewhere
and your question is so the qu the
question is there is about
continuous monitoring you know Dexcom
freestyle Libre these devices that are a
lot more expensive do the same Health
economics necessarily exist because you
obviously still have to have a finger
stick or maybe by the way there are
about four five uh n near infrared
devices that are completely non-invasive
now they're in various stages of
approval they're not widely used yet but
there's a bunch of them out there
sensors and it's all n based so the
question is do this does do the same
Health economics
exist for the much more
expensive these these types of
devices I guess that's my my question
thank you for the question thank you for
appreciating diabetes Educators you're
right it's hard work it's also really
rewarding at times
anyway
[Music]
um I don't have an adequate answer to
your
query and I've had difficulty trying to
find that
data on any
scale so with respect if anybody else is
able to weigh in on that that would be
awesome great thank you I'm still trying
to find
it
represent has a question yeah thank you
uh you you referenc Rhode Island uh
Statute in your testimony uh can you
tell us how many states have uh
legislation
uh identical or similar to what you are
proposing here and then the second part
of my question is we will I'll be
hearing no doubt from insurance company
Representatives what has been the
response to call for this type of of uh
treatment shall we say uh from insurers
such that you believe it's necessary to
bring this forth um as proposed
legislation
thank you for the questions the first
one's easy um there are six states
unless any have passed legislation in
the last two months that I haven't
caught up with um that do have
legislation similar to this and this is
modeled after kind of a compilation from
those States uh Rhode Island
Florida Washington State I want to say
Oklahoma but I'm not 100% certain and I
apologize for my vagueness on some of
this I have a newborn baby granddaughter
so I'm a little um pulled back and forth
in the last couple weeks it's okay if
you just get the the second question um
just follow up later please yeah we we
will have a subcommittee so if you can
have that okay that's fine I can do that
be great thank you and then the second
part of the question so the second
question
is insurance coverage for I would say
both traditional and continous glucose
monitors is in con
assistant
um there are not a lot of patients who
have Commercial Insurance who can't get
any kind of monitor most people can get
a traditional monitor but maybe with
limitations on the
strips but it is not continuous glucose
monitors are not routinely covered for
people with type 2 diabetes which is 90%
of the diabetic population and that's
why why is it not covered are you is
that the question right what are you
hearing from insurers such as that they
won't they're not doing this or won't do
it well they they will testify so
they'll they'll well I'd like to hear
from her opinion yes well her her
testimony I don't have a good answer for
that because it's perplexing to me I I
can't I can't wrap my head around why it
wouldn't make
sense a quick question about the bill
yeah representative pelli I have a thank
you I have a congratulations on your rug
thank you I have a quick question about
Bill specifically so is there the
technology is evolving every day so are
these devices somehow approved so that
insurers would have no ambig ambiguity
as to what devices should be covered my
follow-up question is it just limited to
the devices and it's not um this bill
we're not talking about covering in
insulin itself
correct so the first question um yes
they are all FDA approved um there
aren't all that many of them um but it
would be it does specify FDA approved
devices and in the clause about you know
what's the latest and greatest it's
still FDA approved it's not experimental
we're not in any way asking for coverage
of that sort I'm sorry remind me of the
second
question uh this is limited to the
devices and strips and equipment and um
not to the this is coverage for
prescription insulin drugs correct that
is correct this is entirely about
monitoring so that the patient with
diabetes knows their status this bill is
not at all about coverage of how you
would then address that status how
you're treating diabetes it's just about
knowing how you're doing
ongoing great thank you very much now is
is Nick here oh there he is
okay thank you very much thank you very
much youall have a good
day thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Nick
Trana I am representative from Kean
chesher
one and uh I'm very pleased to be a
co-sponsor of of this bill uh in part
because three years ago just over three
years ago uh my son Henry is now thir
um he was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
he had a health emergency took him to
the emergency room in Kean then he ended
up spending the better part of the next
week in uh Pediatric Intensive Care uh
in Lebanon at at Dartmouth uh we have
gone on you know a long learning curve
and it's remarkable to me that over the
past even just three years the
availability of testing devices and
treatment has evolved so much uh and and
it's been really heartening to see when
when Henry first came home after his
diagnosis he was for for some time I
forget how long doing the uh the finger
sticking doing it several times a day
this is particularly difficult um in an
adolescent uh because of hormonal
changes and other chemical changes in
the body that can lead to spikes and
lows in kind of unpredictable ways and
so there was a lot of testing uh it's
especially true when you're talking
about children who are playing sports
right so you have the Adolescent uh
hormones and chemical changes combined
with the effects of vigorous exercise on
uh and heat right also can can
exacerbate those things so uh he was
doing a lot of testing it's also uh an
issue during the school day right when
he would have to leave class frequently
he ended up if total the amount of time
that he missed class because if he
started to feel low and he would have to
go to the nurse's office in order to be
stuck in order to be tested it was a
significant amount of time that he would
be missing class uh he would be missing
chunk of his he'd have to eat his lunch
very quickly because part of his
lunchtime was taken up with going down
to the nurse getting tested uh and then
having his lunch and often that meant
he'd have to eat lunch very very quickly
so um we were very thankful to have uh
that device uh and to be able to monitor
him but it was definitely a
challenge uh then he moved moved on to a
freestyle Libre some of you may be
familiar with this uh it was on his arm
uh and he could test it uh now not with
a finger stick but with a device that
came with the freestyle libbre that he
could hold up to his phone and then or
hold up to the device uh and then
eventually an app on his phone that was
really great because he uh not only
didn't have to stick his finger there
was always a backup for that in certain
circumstances you still want to be able
to to do a direct blood test because
they're measuring things slightly
differently uh but one of the nice
things about that was that my wife and I
could download apps on our phones so
that when he tested his blood sugar at
different times of day that he was able
to we could see that on our phones it
also tracked his blood sugar over the
course of of time and his uh uh
specialist up at Dartmouth was able to
access that data and so you could get a
day by day week by week month by month
readout to see when highs occurred when
lows occurred and it allowed for
adjustment which happened uh quite
frequently as they said not uncommon as
I understand it with adolescent
diabetics so that was a really great
step in the right direction um it
malfunctioned I I don't want to say a
lot but enough that again finger
sticking was was quite common and then
he would also always have to inject
himself so leaving the classroom for
example missing school time to go to the
nurse's office to uh you know he could
test it himself but to get the injection
several times a day depending on where
his blood sugar was still had to go to
the nurse's office so that didn't uh
that didn't go
away now he is on a Dexcom which is
really great this is a pump uh has
something in his arm and he has has the
pump which is really great for all of
these things right so that uh it can
test uh regularly and it can provide
regular uh injections at he needs them
in order to keep his blood sugar in the
appropriate range it's great when he's
playing sports as you can imagine early
on he wasn't thrilled about he's out on
the baseball field and my wife and I can
read his blood sugar level and we have
to go out there and tell him you know in
front of his friends like look you
really need to come in so we can give
you a shot or you can get sugar or uh uh
get get something to eat Etc now all of
that is monitored he can take care of
that himself likewise uh in school he is
able to manage that that uh himself uh
and also before he had the uh the Dexcom
he would have uh and I apologize I'm not
going to get the uh the names right but
he would have the fast acting insulin
that he would take during the day but he
also had I think it was Humalog which is
long lasting at night so that's it's a
separate uh prescription it's a separate
uh drug uh that you would use in order
to cover that overnight period we don't
have to do that anymore the continuous
glucose monitor monitors that overnight
and if he gets low it provides him these
little uh doses boluses rather than
larger uh units which is a much more
effective way of of controlling uh his
blood sugar
overnight when we first were prescribed
the
Dexcom we got it approved H and then it
just didn't come and it didn't come and
it didn't come and so we followed up I
spent numerous hours on the phone with
our insurance company trying to
understand why
it turns out that our insurance company
had changed how they cover the Dexcom
had originally been under a prescrib
prescription drug plan but they changed
it without telling us to durable medical
supplies and they had just kind of
cancelled the order rather than telling
us that we needed to talk to our
physician get a new order put in you
know they said that's the other side of
the company you know our computer
doesn't talk to their computer so it
took a long time to to to get it going
when it wasn't clear that insurance was
was going to cover it we were going to
pay for it ourselves because the the
benefits are really great uh we were
looking at about $300 a month uh for
that in addition to other things that we
pay for monthly and uh this is a
significant uh obviously significant um
outlay I'm fortunate to have good
insurance I have a good job I have good
pay so it would have been not pleasant
for us to pay that uh in addition to all
the other things that we have to pay for
but it would have been doable uh
fortunately Insurance did end up um
everything got straightened out and now
it's $40 a month as opposed to the 300
that we would have been spending in
addition to other costs so for us to do
that as I said it would not have been
pleasant but it would have been possible
and we would have done it I can only
imagine you know the number of grand
estaters if we're looking at 6600 people
a year how many of those are children um
who are not eligible for example for
Medicaid but who are also you know would
really financially be put in a bind if
they're looking at $300 to $500 a month
just for that device uh in addition to
the other costs that uh representative
Damon spoke about that come along with
with treating diabetes so um I won't I'm
happy to ask or answer rather any
questions I wanted to share that as an
example of kind of the progression
particularly with a child with diabetes
and the importance of these devices and
how expensive they can be and uh and how
much it would mean for a lot of folks in
the granite state to make sure that they
don't have to worry about either paying
that out of pocket or possibly not being
able to afford to do that in a
reasonable way so thank you very much
for hearing my
testimony representative Gibbs thank you
is the Dex Dexcom is that correct Dexcom
that your son has um a combined device
that both monitors and ad ministers
medication when needed yes it is I thank
you for the question and and it was this
weird with the insurance one thing that
gets complicated is there's the pump
which actually our insurance company
said sure we'll cover that no problem
and it came in the mail but then you
also need to get the cartridges that
contain the insulin that go into the
device and that's what they weren't
going to cover right so you can get the
pump free right but 300 bucks a month
for the cartridges uh that go into the
the pump so he does have one of those
devices that both monitors and then
administers okay represent
spear I don't know uh for sure if you
would know the answer to this
question your son is obviously on
insulin but if he if a person did not
require insulin would they have access
to any kind of monitoring at all through
insurance
I can't answer that question
unfortunately representa M thank you Mr
chairman so just to clarify it's two
separate devices correct the Dexcom and
then they integrate with at least one
that I know of Tandem I think but I
think perhaps others too so Dexcom is
Dexcom CGM is CGM insulin pump is you
have a question now so I'm just trying
to clarify right clarify that because I
think there's some confusion amongst
okay like what Dean came and invented
which was just an insulin pump got it in
the 70s or something right it's an
integrated
system okay two two separate devices
though right one's monitoring one's drug
delivery yes they just talk to each
other electronically yes got it okay any
other questions seeing none thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
very much Mr
chairman okay so I think we got a good
idea of what we're dealing with here so
let's hear the insurance company's
position uh we'll start with
Heidi roll who represents
ahip and it is still morning barely good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Heidi C I work at Gallagher Callahan and
gartell and I represent ahip which is um
America's health insurance plans or the
trade Association for the health
insurance carriers um so we um do have
concerns about the bill
um I guess I would first um turn
people's attention to the Bill's fiscal
note
um which was prepared by the insurance
department um so it um explains what the
bill does and
um some flags that they have uh flagged
for us um so as we've heard discussion
today um the bill does seek to um uh
expand coverage for diabetes U
monitoring supplies and equipment for
individuals um with diabetes that do not
currently use um insulin therapy um so
it would increase the eligible
population for the service and as the
department indicates in their fiscal
note um it would increase the eligible
population um
significantly
um the bill is also seeking to um uh cap
the insured uh cost share responsibility
to no more than
$30 um for a 30-day Supply um regardless
of whether the patient has um met their
deductible yet or not
um you know I think this is an important
Point um the costs don't go away uh the
costs would need to be picked up um
elsewhere you know it's it's like a
balloon if you squeeze the cost out of
one area they're going to have to go
into something else um so it would put
upward pressure on premiums um and or uh
cause upward pressure on other uh cost
sharing co-pays um cost shares um for
other services um in the health plan um
so the the department indicates in its
um fiscal note that um you know the bill
would uh would increase the frequency
unit cost and total cost of claims the
department expects the extent of this
increase to be non-trivial but
indeterminable at the time at this time
and um this may result in upward
pressure on premiums and and we would
agree with that assessment
um I also would say that when you place
a cap like this of
$30 um you are essentially given giving
the manufacturers of the equipment um no
incentive whatsoever to keep their
prices affordable and so um the sky is
the limit for them once you put in a cap
like this where
um insurance is basically paying you
know the premium payers are basically
paying um for anything above the
$30 um I also wanted to point out um
that the way the bill is drafted um this
would apply only to the um fully insured
markets so the individual small group
and large group fully insured um so it's
not applying to the self-funded market
which is about 34% of New Hampshire's
Insurance Market um the group the
employer sponsored market fully insured
somewhere around 20 to
21% um the individual Market is um under
6% so this bill would Target you know
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
28% of the insurance Market um putting
aside Medicaid I'm not here to talk
about the Medicaid piece um so I just
wanted to and the other um type of
carriers or insurance that would not be
covered by this um are folks who have
outof state employers who don't have
brick and mortar here in New Hampshire
so if you're working either remotely um
for an out of state company or you're
working you live in New Hampshire but
you work in Massachusetts or Vermont or
Maine um chances are that um that out of
state employer would not
if if that's your situation you're out
of state employer would not be covered
by this either um and I say that only
because we have situations where we pass
mandates and then a year or so later
people come back and they complain we
passed the Mandate my insurance company
is's still not covering and it's because
your insurance company is not um you
know the law does not apply to
them
um you know I think um in terms of
coverage you know if we do have medical
necessity requirements um so what
carriers are doing applying in a fair
and Equitable way is to apply the
medical necessity standards um so if
it's medically necessary it's covered um
there just because something is covered
doesn't mean a patient doesn't have a
cost share
um uh the only services that are
available without a cost share are ones
that are deemed um to be preventative
Services Under the Affordable Care Act
as you heard from the insurance
department at the beginning of this um
this goes beyond what's deemed under the
Affordable Care Act to be um
preventative
Services um finally I'd say in a couple
of places here you'll see that um the
bill would remove prior authorization we
do have a concern with that prior
authorization well not everybody likes
it um it's there for a reason it's there
um both provide um uh safety and kind of
quality of care for the patient and it's
also there to U make sure that we manage
costs um also I did notice in the bill
it requires the carrier must guarantee
coverage of new diabetes equipment and
supplies as they come into the market
and again um new equipment t t tends to
come with a high price tag um and so I
think what we' we would not want to take
away the flexibility to make sure that
we're using equipment um that is um you
know the most cost-effective available
and still doing the job so um we would
have a concern with that section as well
and as you heard earlier from the
insurance department um the state would
have a responsibility as drafted um for
additional costs under this there's the
cost of frail
issue um and finally uh the effective
date is written as 60 days after passage
typically when we um require mandates um
or have new mandate laws we at least try
to sync them up with the plan year um
which would be the first of a new
year
um and with that I will keep my remarks
short I don't want to stand between you
and lunch I know there are other
speakers well we do have questions here
we'll start with representative Sullivan
thank you um so I'm curious I don't
think you really touched on do you or
does the insurance industry have a
position on what the sponsor suggested
which is this is kind of penny
uh Pennywise and pound foolish in terms
of this would actually reduce overall
costs I mean surely you guys have
studied it or perhaps you haven't like
it it what she said makes sense to me
but what's your perspective yeah I and I
think you know Insurance like I said
insurance carriers provide um follow
medical necessity guidelines those
medical necessity guidelines are uh
continuously evolving um they are
developed um by um folks who are outside
of the insurance company they're you
know developed by um experts in the
field looking at Best Practices you know
most current standards um and so my
understanding um and I'm not an expert
on this but my understanding is that um
that the continuous um monitoring is if
you're on insulin then it's you know
it's recommended or you know more likely
to be recommended if you're not then
it's my understanding is that it's not a
typical um
you know typically
recommended further question question um
so and then just I'm sympathetic to your
point about the $30 cap I I see what
you're saying it could lead to a higher
cost because the patient's only going to
ever pay $30 of it uh if if this bill
you know goes further do you think it
would be a better idea to do something
like they pay a share 10% of it if the
average price is 30 bucks
or if the average price is $300 10%
would get us to
$30 that way if you have a newer one
coming online then a patient might have
an incentive to say hey I don't want to
pay 10% of a high cost one but this
other one which maybe isn't as techy but
it it will cause them to choose that
basically because they're impacted by
the price point right absolutely um
would that be an amendment perhaps it
might be a little bit more appealing to
the industry so I mean I think the way
things normally would work now is that
you know if there's
um when things are covered there's
negotiated contracts whether it's a
service or a piece of equipment so the
patient gets the uh advantage of the
negotiated price um until they've met
their deductible and then once they've
met their deductible they're either
paying a co-pay or a co- Insurance um
and you're right um insurance companies
provi try to provide incentives for
people to use lower cost Alternatives
that are equally effective
um because they are paying a co-pay or
co- insurance so you know typically um
there's incentives where you'll have a
lower co-pay if you're using something
that's a lower cost and you try to
encourage you to go in that way in that
way so I think that's actually how
things are happening now so this cap
this cap of $30 would diverge yeah just
to be clear you know if you look in the
bill where the print the $30 is current
law and like it for not for the new
language obviously but for under the
under the current statue and I would say
it's I've been around long enough where
it originally was passed it was $100 and
then we lower it to $30 and this is not
for the new group of people this is for
the insulin right now you can see right
the $30 for insulin but this also
proposes a $30 cap on the equipment
exactly but I'm just saying the 30
that's where the 30 comes from is that
we actually statutorily required it for
insulin Reverend s
spear oh there any actual
Actuarial um information that indicates
if you have type one oh I don't even I'm
not sure I would get it right the kind
that doesn't require insulin whichever
type that is I don't know what that
is I I don't I'd have to look into that
oh sorry here's my question if you have
whatever type that is is there any
Actuarial information that
indicates how serious of one of these k
kidney diseases or heart failures or any
of this are likely to
occur I can look into that I'm sure
there is I mean insurance carriers don't
want people having more expensive
episodes of care either I mean we're all
I think we all have the same goal of
keeping people healthy so that they're
um not getting sick not having to go to
the hospital you
know having other um more severe impacts
but I I don't I'm not aware of that I'm
sure there's that information out there
I can can we get that information yeah
so um I will tell you that uh as someone
who has experience with uh type one
which is juvenile um yes they often lose
limbs okay what I want to say is is that
um when we talk to a lobbyist who is not
a doctor is not a health care provider
it's hard to ask them these type of
questions so that they're they're uh we
can no there is no actual AR uh the the
end of the day it's always a good you
know you hear the um that U so a lot of
juvenile that are very uh brittle uh
they're just in terms of how bad and how
often they test and and and there are
some some you know how good they are on
maintaining in so yes um we we we over I
I think juny blazedale was was a
juvenile diabetic and he lived as he was
a Senator Senate State pres Senator
president he lived for a very long time
so but some do not and it's it's all
over the map okay representa Terry thank
you um uh you referenced in the fiscal
note you referenced us to the fiscal
note and then I heard in your testimony
you
indicate um costs non-trivial
indeterminant at the same time I believe
since you're representing um ahip that
this is a 50 state assoc Association and
we have heard in testimony that there
are six other states that have passed
similar or identical legislation to that
which is being proposed if you do not
have the data readily available for us
today would you supply this committee
with experience uh data from the six
states that have enacted such
legislation so that we can begin to
gauge the fiscal impact of this uh
proposed
legislation if it were to come into
effect in some way shape or form here in
New
Hampshire um and particularly with
respect to the effect that we we all
acknowledge that diabetes and we've
heard today from the sponsor the
diabetes has a cascading effect in terms
of deleterious consequences so that with
respect to the data that would come to
us through you from the Six States your
colleagues in the other Six States stes
that one would one would
surmise that there would be uh there
there would be a reduction in the costs
of
insurance
payouts uh on the basis of the fact that
the diabetes would be better
controlled so could you do that for us I
will I will I'm happy to look in to see
what information is available from other
states I would think that's critical for
us critical I don't know what available
what data is available but I will look
forward it that's going to be pretty
tricky day because the problem is people
don't stick with the same insurance
company all the way through so it's hard
to to collect that I would ALS I would
also say that from what I from what that
that would be a tough one to so Mr is
this a matter if we don't know until we
know because we can't know until we know
u i I'll take this moment to say chair
would everybody maybe or did not hear
from what the department said right out
of the get-go which is that um that this
bill would require us to do a financial
analysis and uh and that would take a
year so no matter what we do this bill
is cannot pass this year it will go to
interm study in which the department
will do its study its economic impact
study uh because we need to know what
the and then so next year uh when when
the sponsor reintroduces the bill again
at that point it will have an actual
appropriation that it's going to cost
the state to
implemented gue i' get
reelected I would ALS yeah I agree with
what you're um with what the insurance
department said about the the Mandate
review and then the other piece of this
is the Medicaid piece um the Medicaid
the Medicade is that's the state going
to have to come up cough up with that
money
okay thank you very much all right so
one we just go to the insurance
companies and let's get them out of the
way and then we'll have just the people
who are in supp support of the bill so
next up is
Sabrina laap from
anthm thank you chairman hunt and
members of the committee I'm Sabrina
Dunlap Dunlap I'm director of government
relations at
Anthem um and I just wanted to know I
have family members and very dear family
friends who deal with type 1 diabetes so
I very much appreciate the sensitivity
um of and importance of this topic so we
we do have concerns with how broad the
bill is I won't repeat what Heidi said
but um I spoke with our medical director
and he found this very concerning
because his read on this language is
that this would open it up these devices
to all patients even where not
appropriate um and he noted that there
are specialty societies that do not
recommend the use of these devices in
all patients with type two diabetes I
believe that in the fiscal note um the
American Association of clinical
Endocrinology is cited um and I I can I
can follow up with our medical director
to get the other specialty societies
that do not recommend the devices for
all type two
diabetes um
so I think you know just the breadth of
this um and in just sort of opening the
doors where the devices might not be
clinically appropriate um is probably
the most concerning issue I would also
just know I know Heidi touched on this a
little bit but we do often hear
confusion about coverage versus cost
share and as as Heidi noted you know if
something's medically necessary it's
going to be covered um and just because
someone has a co-pay and they're paying
money they might think well this isn't
covered but it actually is and then you
get into you know benefit design and the
type of plan that you have um so anyway
uh I'm happy to take any questions but
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today and this and this is a real
question not a not a little would you
believe it is a real question yeah no go
ahead thank you for coming for Anthem
how many type one patients do you cover
in New Hampshire if it was limited to
type one so how many so I already know
the your claims experience in
reimbursement so I know what it would
cost but I just don't know how many type
one you have I do not know that off the
top of my head but I could try to look
into that I'm I'm not sure that
something I could answer type one or
covered now this is really a type two
War for type two or people who are have
high a you know do we already we already
mandate coverage for for type one CGM uh
read the read the the print in the bill
I didn't think it was I think it was
read read stuff that's not bold faac
believe you me we've had this bill
several time this I don't think cdms are
mandated no CMS are not that's and
that's the bill right so so so the
followup is if how many cg1 out there
how many type ones so it's about 5% 5 to
10% of the total diabetic po population
there's a 100,000 give or take diabetics
in New Hampshire so it's really about
it's under 10,000 I just want to know
how many Anthem has oh right and they
get they cost them about4 to $6,000
those numbers right what's that I didn't
say anything I said it's
proprietary they're not going to tell us
how many patients they
have okay
thank representative
Gibbs thank you um shouldn't the
question of who needs uh a continuous uh
glucose
monitor be answered by uh the individual
patient's doctor based on the individual
patients needs and not by uh the
recommendations the general
recommendations of a society of
Specialists well thank you for the
question I'm not a medical professional
so I mean I assume that is the current
state though that that is how the system
works is that a provider makes a
recommendation uh hopefully in
accordance with accepted guidelines and
all carriers do our reviews and our
medical directors all work under widely
accepted medical guidelines as
well perfect thank you very much all
right Peter you're the last one Harvard
Pilgrim I'm shocked I would think a
nonprofit would cover all these
things thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee second day in a row I've
had the pleasure of paying you a visit
and uh I'm Peter bragon for the record
um a senior policy adviser with predy
strategies also a recovering House and
Senate member um here representing
Harvard PGM Healthcare as the chairman
mentioned Harvard Pilgrim is a not
for-profit health insurance company the
only uh not for-profit health insurance
company in the state covering the
individual and group markets um and in
saying that um part of that is we don't
have shareholders to answer to we're not
trying to make money for people what
we're looking for is what is the best
long-term solution so one of the prior
questions had to do with well don't you
look down the road to see if you solve
this problem now then you don't have
this problem later on and certainly that
something we look at all the time time
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare currently
covers continuous long-term glucose
monitoring devices uh the coverage
criteria is based on medical necessity
and the medical necessity is not
something that the board of directors of
Harvard gets together people who are
just you know nothing about medical
issues and make some decision we have
panels of Medical Specialists who review
all the available literature uh and in
the case of glucose monitoring devices
uh the sources we use for for our
medical necessity criteria are the
American Association of clinical end
Endocrinology Who currently recommends
glucose monitor devices for individuals
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes um and
those diagnosed with type two uh who
also use insulin therapy also the
sources we use are the American di
Diabetes Association uh the 2023
standards of care uh it was mentioned
earlier they've just updated that
obviously we regularly update um our
medical criteria based on the latest um
criteria from the groups that understand
these issues the best and obviously if a
provider requests something that doesn't
fit within our medical guidelines um
then there is an appeal process if it
doesn't fit in to make an explanation as
to why the provider thinks that these
other groups may be wrong on an issue so
it's not just uh uh on a whim that these
decisions are made um let's see I'll
point out uh uh Heidi mentioned that
these types of bills and I should say
Let Me Take A a step back as well
there's going to be a number of bills
you're going to see this year and you're
going to hear me several times uh
Express concerns about them uh bills
that basically say we don't that neglect
medical necessity that we should do
various things for various other reasons
other than medical reasons and those may
all be well and good policy decisions
but you have to understand that's a
slippery slope you go down there's going
to be bills on Prosthetics on
infertility treatments on blood uh lead
testing uh there's this bill here that
basically says uh no medical necessity
required at all just do this so that's a
that's a concern overall because those
costs have to go somewhere and they're
going to go to the people who pay the
premiums and we all know that insurance
premiums are high enough I pay my own
insurance premiums they're high enough
the way it is uh all these types of
things are going to increase the
pressure on those as well as bills like
this one that uh take away any cost
sharing or at least try to limit the
cost sharing of the subscriber so
basically that means it's going to go to
the premiums so um our view is as a not
for-profit is we want to make it so the
premiums are affordable so as many
people in companies can have this as
possible um and so we're dealing with uh
the issue of only 20% as Heidi said of
the um Employers in the state or people
in the state would be covered by the
fully insured plans let me also point
out that that means it doesn't include
state employees why do we pass all these
State mandates to cover various things
but say oh but the state won't have to
pay for this for this employees it
doesn't also doesn't cover the cities
and towns and school districts in
Hampshire which are covered by RSA 5B as
risk pools why don't we mandate that
they cover this as well if we really
concerned about covering these things we
should make that a part of the Mandate
as well uh let's see this bill would as
I uh indicated uh override medical
criteria require coverage of glucose
monitoring devices and supplies to in
individuals diabetes that do not
currently use insulin therapy um and for
whom a continuous glucose monitor may
not be medically necessary uh the fiscal
note indicates there are only
575 uh people I believe in the state
that currently under the commercial
insurance Market that have glucose
marting devices um the testimony
indicated there's close to 100,000
people in the state that may have
diabetes or that's the ones diagnosed um
so if you make this available to
everybody then just consider what that
will do to the price uh that people have
to pay for their premiums um I guess
that's the basic thing is there's
medical criteria out there they are not
developed on a whim they're not just
throwing darts at a wall we use these
professional organizations that
understand these diseases and their
causes and their treatments and the
ramifications thereof uh to make
recommendations on what's appropriate so
that we can be the best fiscal stewards
of the premium dollars that we have I'd
be happy to answer any questions thank
you for your time
Mr okay represent Terry thank you so one
of the states that was identified that
had uh that has uh enacted this
legislation is Rhode Island I presume
that's within your uh your business uh
territory I made a note represent a
check on uh what's so I was wondering if
you would uh check and get back to us on
the experience that Harvard Pilgrim has
had because yes it makes sense that that
premiums would initially increase to
cover these additional shall we call
them benefits for the lack of a better
term right now um but then we've also
acknowledge that there are net gains in
terms of the reduction of costs to have
to pay for other conditions because the
blood glucose is being controlled within
an appropriate range so if you could get
if you could get that data from Rhode
Island to us we'd appreciate it yes
thank you represent I did make a note of
not indal all the states being curious
but rhod Island obviously in the New
England area be representative Gibs
thank you uh I'm going to ask you a
question similar to the one that I asked
the anthem representative and that is
shouldn't the question of medical
necessity for an individual patient be
answered by that patient physician based
on the individual patients needs and not
by
a pattern uh I'm sorry not by a panel of
medical experts uh making a general
recommendation or by a society of
experts making a general recommendation
because as I'm sure you're aware um uh
needs of individ individual patients uh
vary thank you for the question I
certainly understand the concern I guess
I would say as I pointed out that
there's an appeal process so if a
provider for some reason thinks that the
American Diabetes associate
uh doesn't know what they're talking
about or is misunderstanding a certain
issue they can bring that before the
panel but for a vast majority of cases
um these guidelines present what the
experts think should be done but there
is a way to bypass that if someone
thinks they uh decision needs to be made
outside of those recommendations but
these groups spend full time studying
the best treatment for these uh diseases
and
conditions representative Herbert um I'm
not sure you know the answer to this but
I'm going to ask anyway the um is there
any um in terms of federal funds is
there any interaction here
whereas uh some of the the federal
government under Medicaid or Medicare or
some program would uh also chip in in
order to pay pay these bills is there
any access that way thank you for the
question certainly part of this bill
deals with Medicaid and that obviously
would uh have a lot of federal
interaction but to my understanding at
least on the commercial insurance side
individual and small group Market I
don't believe there's anything like
that representative
Sullivan so when you talk about the
panel that helps set up these guidelines
can you tell us who's on these panels do
they include a wide range of people or
yeah thank you for the question I can
get you information on kind of the the
types of people that are on this uh
there uh I I most insurance companies
probably work the same way there was a a
medical director that over sees the
entire thing and then uh then panels of
other medical professionals with
specialty or expertise or at least
knowledge in these areas uh to make
recommendations but I can get you some
better information on that and you know
obviously medical necessity is um a term
that for those of us who've been on this
committee a long time are acutely aware
so I think I might uh have the
department come in and make a little bit
of a presentation explain how uh the
medical director how the process that
occurs
uh in terms of these decisions and and
but but I will reemphasize what he just
said is is that if the doctor does
prescribe and the insurance company will
say no we won't do won't do it if the
doctor really does believe that this
patient is appropriate is um uh the
legislation which I sponsored I was
going to say who sponsored that
legislation we have the uh external
review process uh that in a timely
fashion will address the issue and and I
and I my understanding is the external
review has been very successful for
patients thank you very much thank you
okay we have uh five cards left um and I
would just say to all of you uh you
stand between us and lunch and you know
how important getting our lunch is right
so um I I have some cards like 10
minutes please please let's try to focus
on making a point that has not not been
made already you know that's all I can
ask okay so Joan
arjal thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee my name is
Janan archabald I am the director of
policy and government Affairs for on Sky
Community Services um we are an agency
that Services individuals with
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders I usually come before
committees and speak on behalf of the
families um to tell their stories but
today I can speak on my own story um 12
years ago my daughter was diagnosed with
type 1 diabetes we lived here in New
Hampshire um they weren't able to care
for her here so they airlifted her down
to Boston where she was um placed in the
ICU for a while and at the time um
people came out and said we're five
years from a cure and
so and I was sitting out in the lobby
one day and the old older doctor came by
and he said how you doing said I said
I'm fine we at 5 Years From a cure and
he
said I'm going to give you some advice
he goes we've been 5 Years From a cure
for as long as I've been around he goes
in the absence of a cure technology will
keep your daughter alive so that's all I
needed to hear at the time 12 years ago
there wasn't as much technology
available as there is today cgms were
not um available for Pediatric use at
the time so I've lived before the day of
CGM and after the day of CGM and I can
tell you um before these devices were
available what life was like 10 times a
day minimum for insurance coverage and
for our endocrinologist so that meant me
getting up two three times in the middle
of the night by her bedside pricking her
finger if her blood sugar was low I'd
spend the night on the floor testing her
every 20 minutes to make sure she was
safe to go to sleep every morning she
would wake up and I would say a prayer
saying thank God she woke up this is the
life that I led before cgms she played
track anything as one of the
representatives just said would affect
her blood sugar heat exercise and
sometimes it's not immediate it could be
4 hours later so she in the middle of
the night she would get a low for after
running track that day so we didn't
sleep much we ate a lot of um grilled
cheeses at 3: in the morning trying to
keep her safe and healthy I quit my job
to go to school um so I could be with
her at school so I could go on field
trips to help her so the nurse wouldn't
be overburdened with just her care it
was that much work um then cgms were
approved and this is a life Cher it made
all the difference in the world and if
you don't know what they are I brought
one and they've changed forms over the
last 12 years they've gotten better
every year you can wear them longer
they're smaller this is the device that
goes on her body it's just little tiny
transmitter and this is the sensor that
inserts it so this puts a base in her
stomach where she plugs this in it goes
to a Bluetooth connection to her phone
and it also goes to my phone so I can
watch or whoever's phone that she wants
to put it on and what we do is she's at
college now which is terrifying if
you're a parent of a diabetic um so she
keeps you can set the alert she says
okay if my blood sugar gets below 100 it
it alerts now it doesn't only alert at
that threshold but if she's crashing for
some reason and and it will tell you
you're you're crashing hard so you can
do
proactive administration of your blood
sugars and so I set mine 20 points lower
than hers so if she hits 70 I know that
she's in trouble and I call her and then
I call her boyfriend and then I call her
friends and then I call the police so
that's sort of our little thing so she
makes sure that I don't get to the third
line of defense there so she um it's a
great sort of proactive
tool on once I found the benefit of this
I said this is it everybody needs this
device so I became an activist I was
actively involved in the CGM Medicare
access act in 20 5 which allowed
Medicare to cover cgms um for seniors
and it took about two years of lobbying
our federal delegation but it did pass
and um you know as one the other
representativ says one of the highlights
of that testimony that I listen to was
talking about driving they were saying
that seniors when they're driving long
distances the rhythmic sort of um motion
of a car could masquerade a low blood
sugar so not only does it keep them safe
but it keeps everyone else on the road
Road
safe so I just wanted to tell
you how this has impacted my life how
it's impacted everyone's else's life and
I just hope you could keep that in
consideration diabetes is expensive my
husband and I both work we max out our
fsas every year I think this year was
2750 we could each deduct for FSA and
that money is gone by the summer 90% of
that goes to her it it's gone before
that if one of us has a test or
something but um it's a lot and I'm
grateful that I have the opportunity to
be able to help her um but she worries
about it too she's graduating in a year
she's like I don't know how I'm going to
afford my diabetes supplies and that
kind of breaks my heart because I want
her to I want her to follow her heart
and take a job that she wants to do not
a job that she has to do because of her
health
issues thank you thank you for coming
and sharing that
story okay uh Liz Bennett Bennett uh
Ken it it's okay yes it is
okay you don't make it okay that way but
works for
me
caer can you just
press there there we go okay thank you
uh I'm a registered nurse and a
certified Diabetes Care and education
specialist previously known as a CDE uh
or diabetes
educator I have 38 years of experience
in this field I'm also the Grassroots
leader of our local body of diabetes
Educators and I am in support of this
bill you've already heard a lot about
cgms um and how they
continuously uh measure blood sugar and
that this data can be communicated to a
smartphone a smart watch and uh as our
previous speaker said it can also be
communicated to the uh smartphone of a
parent of a child with
diabetes according to the American
Diabetes Association 2023 executive
summary on Health Equity in diabetes
technology and this is what we're
talking about is the upcoming diabetes
technology for all people living with
diabetes continuous glucose monitors or
cgms provide significant potentially
life-changing benefits
for diabetes management and in turn for
avoidance or delay of serious
comorbidities hospitalizations and even
death well how did this system work the
CGM communicates a blood sugar to a
phone the person with diabetes knows
immediately where their blood sugar is
whether it's safe whether it's too low
too high or whether it's trending in an
unsafe
Direction wearing a CGM is similar to
having a gas gauge in a car or a blood
sugar gauge in your body in the early
stages of diabetes the body does give a
warning when the blood sugar is going
too low many lose that warning over the
years many lose that warning when
they're on
medications such as beta blockers that
prevent them from
experiencing the symptoms of low blood
sugar they can't tell where the blood
sugar is running people can become dis
disoriented lose Consciousness have
seizures a CGM warns a person that they
have low blood sugar or trending in that
direction they can then treat themselves
and prevent a serious health problem
ladies and gentlemen gas gauges for
vehicles have been standard since
1920 gas gauges have long prevented
folks from being stranded with an empty
tank by the side of the road well isn't
it time that persons with diabet IES
have an accurate and continuous blood
sugar gauge for their
bodies by supporting this bill you can
PR prevent a person with diabetes from
losing Consciousness while driving a car
and believe me I have been involved in a
number of incidents where uh I have been
in contact with people that were
hospitalized because they crashed their
vehicle because their blood sugar went
too low it can prevent a dangerous fall
in people of any age group because
there's not enough blood getting into
the brain because there's not enough
blood getting to the uh the tissues we
have seen people break hips because of
these kinds of incidences taking
place in both situations many many
situations uh expensive emergency room
visits or hospitalizations can be
prevented let's make this life-changing
technology available to persons with
diabetes in New Hampshire and I'd be
happy to take any of your
questions
representative
spear the kinds of incidences that
you're talking about are you talking
about people with type one or type two
diabetes I am talking up PE about people
with both kinds of diabetes okay type
one are individuals that use insulin
this has also happened to type two
diabetes using uh individuals using
insulin it has also happened to
individuals who are on a group of
medications called uh sulon uas
uh these are an older School of drugs
that are available but they uh actually
stimulate the pancreas to make more
insulin but it it it's it's like a um it
makes insulin constantly you can't turn
it off so individuals that are on these
oral meds for diabetes the sulon uas in
particular okay can have a problem with
their blood Su going low and they can
also have the same uh complications as
people with type 1 diabet IES and that
they lose their warning signs for low
blood sugar they can't tell where it is
at as they're driving uh they can't tell
where it is at when they're sleeping um
many many people have experienced low
blood sugar while they're asleep uh and
have had devastating
consequences thank you very
much uh chair we're calling Emily
DuPont
and I hope it won't be whole eight
minutes I hope you can they're already
covered a lot so great that's very fun
some appreciate it thank you thank you
for your time my name is Emily Dupont
I'm a registered nurse a certified
Diabetes Care and education specialist
but more importantly why I'm here today
is to tell you I'm the wife of a person
with type 1
diabetes the American Diabetes
Association releases the standards of
care and diabetes annually which we've
talked about within those standards are
evidence-based practice recommendations
and support for the optimal management
of diabetes when one of those
evidence-based practice standards is the
use of glucose monitoring for diabetes
management both the finger stick
monitoring and continuous glucose
monitoring in these standards are
recommended to be incorporated into
individualized treatment plans for those
with type 1 type two gestational
diabetes and
hypoglycemia the Ada also recommends
that patients with diabetes maintain an
average glucose of less than 154 which
translates to a hemoglobin A1c
percentage of 7% for optimal
management continuous gluc glucose
monitoring devices which I'll call cgms
do the same as do what the name implies
they continuously check your sugar and
deliver a value to a handheld device a
cell phone or an insulin pump the price
of these cgms can run between $160 to
$500 a month depending on the CGM and
insurance coverage or high deductible or
lack thereof when CGM use is implemented
it makes significant positive changes in
the user's quality of life because it
helps to drive Behavior change I
personally have a patient who came to me
for the first time with an A1c of 11.9%
a weight of 403 lb and an inability to
walk long distances this individual is
retired and living on a fixed income
they discussed having received diabetes
education before but felt incredibly
discouraged with their management up to
this point we discussed CGM use and they
agreed to try it there was no medication
changes occurring at this time because
he was not agreeable to that plan of
care by introducing CGM and the patient
making lifestyle modifications based on
the results that he received from the
CGM his A1C reduced from 11.9% to 7.6%
in three months then another reduction
to 6.5% in 4 months with a total weight
loss of 65 pounds so far their once
average glucose at any given time was
386 exposing them to a very real and
very expensive risk factors of unmanaged
diabetes this risk has been
significantly reduced as his average
glucose is now 127 with no significant
hypoglycemic events meaning they're able
to manage their diabetes and their
glucose safely this aligns with the
Ada's recommendations of maintaining an
A1C of less than 7% or an average
glucose of less than 154 this same
patient is currently facing non-
coverage for CGM supplies and is asking
the same questions that many of my
patients ask how am I going to afford
this if insurance doesn't cover it I
can't lose this tool I've been I haven't
felt this healthy or been this confident
in my diabetes management ever this
device has provided me with the
confidence and security to take back
control of my diabetes it saved my life
in my future
cgms not only help to drive Behavior
change but they provide Safety and
Security for those who do not experience
symptoms of glucose fluctuations for
patients who do not feel symptoms of
life-threatening hypoglycemia which is
increasingly common in the elderly
patient population the CGM alerts the
wear as we've already been told and
allows them to make an intervention
before emergency medical attention is
necessary Switching gears from my
professional experience for a moment and
to look at the through the vantage point
of a wife of someone with typee 1
diabetes it was heartbreaking for me to
hear my husband tell me when we were
teenagers that he has to always have a
good paying job with good insurance
benefits because he has Type 1 diabetes
and it's going to be expensive for him
to live a healthy life as a teenager his
parents discussed with him the cost of
his diabetes supplies insulin his
insulin pump his pump supplies his
glucose testing supplies emergency
medications for diabetes which tallied
up to requiring to tuck away over $5,000
a year for his diabetes supplies and
this is with having insurance he has had
diabetes since he was 3 years old having
to instill in children that they have no
other option but to obtain a good paying
job with excellent Insurance packages
when they grow up because they developed
a health care condition that wasn't
their fault and has no cure for but is
going to be very financially expensive
for them to pay for if they want to have
equal access to the same Health outcomes
as those without diabetes to teach
children that they will have two and a
half times higher health care costs to
access the very necessary equipment and
medications they require to live just to
live as recommended by the Ada standards
of care we need to be asking ourselves
is that what we want to teach our
children with diabetes I've had very
young adult patients tell me that they
can't afford their testing supplies on
their slightly above minimum wage job
with benefits packages offered at work
and that they feel they're
disappointment to themselves and their
doctors and that they're worried about
their health and their future because
they can't afford their supplies on the
other end of the age Spectrum I've had
many many elderly patients tell me that
they had to pick and choose between what
they can afford for their medications
paying their bills and buying their
diabetes supplies they have to have food
in a roof over their head and they have
to pay their bills they have to have
their expensive medications and their
co-pays but what they're also paying is
that they're and they're not paying it
for in money but is the quality of
health and overall life every time these
individuals are forced to pick and
choose what they can afford for their
health care this month they're paying
with in a reduction of quality of life
going forward forgoing months of testing
and forgoing the ability to make
informed Health decisions based off of
their glucose values means increasing
their risk for complications directly
related to unmanaged diabetes it means
cardiovascular complications and kidney
complications means possible amputations
which you've heard of it means blindness
more procedures more appointments and it
means death because diabetes is the
eighth leading cause of death in the
United States thank
you thank you very
much uh
Gan Brown you have a question over there
oh represent of kids
thank you um as a nurse uh who
specializes in Diabetes Care can you
give us an idea I realize it won't be
exact can you give give us an idea of
how common it is for serious
complications such as uh amputations to
occur in diabetes patients who do not
require
insulin it's in it's incredibly common
we have a lot of patients that don't
require insulin or don't have access but
that don't require insulin that are
managed on oral medications that still
have extremely high a1c's which the the
studies show relate to amputations
blindness and things of that nature so
to answer your question it's very
high okay thanks
chair there Jean Brown there you
go hi I'm Jean Brown and I've been a
resident of gtown New Hampshire for 39
years um I've also worked in several
different um hospitals I'm a certified
Diabetes Care and educational specialist
thank you so much for letting me speak
today um and I'm just going to say um
ditto to what um Emily and Liz already
said so I don't keep you here too long
um but um I did want to share um a
couple of uh stories just to um very
briefly about a couple of patients that
I've had um and I just also wanted to
just quickly show you just what you're
deciding on so this is um um a meter
that checks blood sugar but this meter
requires that you prick yourself with
this okay so if you're doing if you have
to check your blood
sugar um four times a day that means you
have to stab your finger four times a
day okay and then you have to put in a
test strip you have to clean your hands
either wash them or use alcohol and put
the test strip in here you have to
change the Lan set you have to have a
place to dispose of your L sets um this
is time consuming and it gives you a
snapshot in time okay if you're wearing
um a CGM so if you're wearing that on
the back of your arm or you're wearing
one on your abdomen um you can just look
at your phone
and see what your blood sugar is so I
just wanted you to
see okay so this is obviously very
convenient okay so um one patient um I
had is man with type 1 diabetes who
worked in the service industry I mean I
can't be too specific because I can't
give
identifiers um he didn't have very good
insurance he had insurance but he had a
$5,000 deductible um so he had to pay
out of pocket for most of his
supplies um and he I'll will say that
he's a patient that used to run out of
insulin until you guys pass the bill for
insulin affordability so thank you so
much um he was supposed to check his
blood sugar four times a day and part of
that is because your amount of insulin
that you need to take is often
determined by what your blood sugar
reading is if you don't know what your
blood sugar is you don't know how much
insulin to take um unfortunately he
couldn't um check his blood sugar very
much he couldn't afford to do it um his
diabetes control um was very poor he had
neuropathy already that's numbness and
tingling in the fingers and toes he had
some vision
problems um he also had many nights
where he had um extremely low blood
sugars and EMTs had to come to the house
um and he also had
hospitalizations I was able to get this
patient a example um CGM for him to
trial for two weeks um and he did
amazingly well he had no low blood
sugars in the middle of the night his um
blood sugars were much more in control
um and then we were able to get him
another sample so for a whole month of
his life he had the best blood sugars he
ever had unfortunately it was a
temporary fix he could not afford it if
he had the only $30 a month um to pay
for a CGM like the bill is proposing um
that would definitely be a life-changing
event for this
person um the other patient was um a
pregnant woman woman with gestational
diabetes that's kind of like a temporary
diabetes um she had terrible needle
phobia and when I told her that one of
the things we have women with
gestational diabetes they need to test
four times a day um and she just started
to cry and shake and she just had Terri
terrible needle phobia and she said that
she there was no way that she was going
to be able to to do this um so I knew
that a continuous glucose monitor would
be the best thing for her um I gave her
again I put a sample um one on her and
um so we had an idea of how our blood
sugars were doing unfortunately I could
not get the insurance to cover it they
would not accept um the needle phobia as
a reason for this woman eing a
continuous gluc ose monitor so
unfortunately for the rest of her
pregnancy she did not check her blood
sugars and she ended up going into
premature labor and had a preey baby so
um if we can get coverage for um and you
know there's a lot of risk for um women
um they can have premature babies excess
amniotic fluid um and they can also
cause um still
birth so um thank you very much for
considering coverage um of of these
devices with a limited of $30 a month
thank
you any questions
okay we're all set thanks okay Richard
Smith you have the last
word thankfully it will be a short
word
my name is Richard Smith I live in
lden I'm been living with type two
diabetes for over 30 years I'm 85 years
old and because
of
insulin and blood glucose monitoring
I've been a able to live quite well with
it and avoid some of the really awful
complications that are all too common
with
diabetes by passing this
bill you're going to save
lives that's not a
hyperbole that's a
fact you've already heard it many times
I've experienced
it during sleep my blood sugar has
dropped
low thank God for the continuous glucose
monitoring I got an alarm wakes me up I
immediately go to my regular little
blood glucose meter to confirm in fact
it is
Hypoglycemia so I treated them by taking
glucose tablets usually about 15 Gams 15
minutes later I test again so I've been
able to avoid
becom an
unconscious and experience what they
call
dead
so I know it
firsthand you can help people like
me by passing this
bill poorly controlled
diabetes has devastating comp
applications you heard many of them
blindness you've heard about the
comparison of
costs well let's just take one of the
complications that's common in diabetes
loss of kidney
function that means you go into dialysis
into the hospital three times a
week that's 500 bucks a
pop that's
$72,000 not to mention the loss of
quality quality of
life that's what's on the
table so we have within our power within
your
beings to give people like myself the
tools to manage our diabetes and they
don't call it diabetes self management
for nothing we're the ones that got to
manage this thing but we got to have the
tools to do it and those tools are
available and uh so I want thank you for
supporting House Bill
1571 and so you'll have before you a
real live type two diabetic using
insulin i' be happy to answer any
questions you might
have representative Bros I just want is
is a would you believe so I can ask a
question I just want to say it's people
like you and some of the many people who
testified today is how we pass laws um
um all very moving testimony and I think
I think all of you you particularly for
coming in
today you're
welcome thank you okay thank you very
much I would say that anybody who did
read uh if you want to submit your
testimony did the clerk really
appreciates it and uh otherwise I will
read the blue sheet uh Lindsay noo from
siga is
opposed and moving right along H Heather
Stockell from Dublin in support uh Peggy
balone I think babon I think she's a
co-sponsor and
support
um we have Laura McIntyre uh
representing the grand State Hospital
say in
support uh and Jonah wheeler is a
representative Jonah wheeler is in
support and with that I will close the
public
hearing okay guys um all right
so we'll we'll come back at
two
they're yes correct yes I knew that so
that's why I'm not feeling too bad about
this but the ambulance providers who
knows what's that thank you what
nightmare that's going to be so
okay
for
well it's 2 o'clock the chair is not
here so I'm going to hold this in recess
until he
returns
ility about having the same birthday
like if there's a group of 30 people
there's a high probability that has the
same birthday well I forget how to
explain
it
okay let's let's do
okay
I
don't all right ready okay
repres representing MC Beth I am
representing yes good morning I mean
good afternoon I'm Jackie groa I'm the
state representative for Rockingham 24
representing the towns of Ry in
Greenland
and I here um at the request of
Representative MC Beth who is the
sponsor for this bill and I'm here to
ask you to itella
please we can do that thank
you best hearing
ever what you didn't like the one we had
this morning with
me and sweet okay all right moving right
on all right uh as soon as the clerk is
ready we'll take up 12
another
okay
ready turn my mic off okay uh public
hearing
1296 Katherine raro there she is thank
you uh good afternoon members of the
committee uh I'm representative
Katherine Romo I have the pleasure of
representing Hillsboro County District 2
town of Bedford
I'm here to introduce HB 1296 which
relates to insurance coverage for
Diagnostic and supplemental breast
examinations uh in short this bill is uh
to increase earlier detection of breast
cancer by eliminating supplemental
Imaging and examination costs to
patients that deter them from seeking
follow-up and diagnostic
care uh as you may already be aware
getting a mamogram is only the initial
step and is not alone able to diagnose
cancer early detection of breast cancer
is not possible without the medically
necessary diagnostic follow-up or
additional supplemental Imaging required
to rule out breast cancer or to confirm
the need for a biopsy uh while
mammograms are widely covered by
insurance without patient cost sharing
uh some individuals at higher risk of
breast cancer or those requiring
follow-up Imaging due to an abnormal
mamogram results uh face hundreds to
thousands of dollars in further cost
before even potentially being diagnosed
with breast cancer I personally wanted
to sponsor this bill because my mom was
one of the estimated 12 to 16% of women
screened for uh mammogram required
follow-up Diagnostic Imaging resulting
in a breast cancer diagnosis that we're
very lucky she was able to treat over
many months um while she was able to
afford her Diagnostic Imaging that not
everyone is as
fortunate I know others in this room
have also supported wives and sisters
daughters and mothers through this
difficult journey and some have lived
through breast cancer themselves it is
my hope that with this legislation more
women will not let Financial barriers
delay an early diagnosis of breast
cancer and further delay treatment
options by detecting breast cancer early
these exams can save lives and reduce
the need for more invasive and expensive
treatments I have a few statistics I'd
like to share with you it is estimated
that 40% of women in the US have dense
breast tissue and this dense tissue
makes it more difficult to detect breast
cancer through a
mamogram average out-of-pocket costs for
Diagnostic Imaging examinations range
from
$234 to
$1,021 in 2023 alone more than
1,390 individuals were diagnosed with
breast cancer and more than 180 died in
New Hampshire from breast
cancer research suggests that when women
with dense breast tissue do not receive
supplemental breast exams up to onethird
of breast cancer diagnoses can be missed
the longer it takes for women to detect
breast cancer the quicker their 5-year
survival rates
decline according to a recent Maryland
study the estimated cost impact of
eliminating cost sharing requirements
for Diagnostic Imaging examinations uh
for Diagnostic evaluation of the breast
put at 7 cents per member per month or
about 83 cents per year uh according to
a recent Massachusetts study requiring
coverage for Diagnostic examinations
would result in an estimated average
increase to the typical member's monthly
health insurance premium between 19
cents and 33 cents per member per month
Medicaid provides these diagnostic exams
and no cost to patients and similar
legislation has been enacted in 20
States across the country already
including Maine and Connecticut it's
pending in Vermont Massachusetts but
also Texas Tennessee uh Missouri um all
over the country it's it's really
widespread uh this legislation has been
successful um imposing cost sharing on
these exams can discourage individuals
from seeking necessary care leading to
delays and diagnosis and treatment that
can have serious
consequences by eliminating cost sharing
health insurance policies we can provide
individuals with the care they need to
stay healthy and prevent much more
serious health issues from arising in
the future it is important to ensure
that all women regardless of their
breast density or other risk factors
have access to comprehensive breast
cancer screening exams when appropriate
so that breast cancer is detected
earlier when it is most treatable I know
you're considering many bills I
appreciate your attention today I ask
the committee to vote a to pass on hb1
1296 um thank you for your time I'm
happy to answer any questions as best I
can as well as to uh defer to some
upcoming
testimony representative
s thanks um so you said that this has
been passed or a version of this has
been passed in a few other states you
named some of them has there been so it
sounds
like the bill says it's going to require
uh no cost sharing for anything that for
any insurance plan that has coverage
currently right so right now there's
cost sharing are there any plans that
don't have coverage for these sorts of
procedures or is that essentially every
plan that we have so mammograms and
again testimony after me can correct me
if I'm wrong my understands mammograms
are generally covered but without cost
to the patient um but that once if you
need followup or additional Imaging or
for diagnosis that is not entirely
covered there is patient cost for that
followup testing or Imaging okay all
right cool
thanks okay
um I feel like this is Deja Vu I mean I
I
heard we did
uh I remember was we the big debate was
3D 3D mammograms or 3D years and and the
har it was the Harvard medical director
who who didn't like it is that what this
bill is about or I mean why why do we
what we already have right now we're in
compliance with Affordable Care Act that
any me uh uh this should already be
mandated I mean what what insurance
company's not covering this now I guess
I should ask why do this they're they're
not covering all patients are still
incurring costs from the $234 to $1,000
for some of this followup it's not just
about the 3D imaging necessarily though
it it's about diagnostic screening I
have others who can testify uh in
further detail but I don't think it's it
is the same as what you previously heard
not this not the breast examination this
is something different it's for followup
Imaging uh what does that mean meaning
if there if there something that in the
additional mamogram that looks
problematic that you need further
Imaging or further Imaging to actually
reach a diagnosis or to determine if you
needed a biopsy for further testing uh
you need further Imaging especially for
dense breast tissue that won't show up
necessarily in a typical mamogram you're
saying the insurance companies are not
covering this I'm saying that they're
not covering all the cost patients are
still paying out of pocket cost for that
followup Imaging so I can only imagine
that the only people who are if the
insurance company is not is rejecting it
or not doing it it's got to be ais's
it's got to be because under the
Affordable Care Act it's required so my
understanding is that under the
Affordable Care Act mammograms are
covered entirely um but I I well I will
have testimony following with can answer
that question further right well I can
just say that I I don't see any
opposition from anybody so I can only
imagine that the people who really who
are okay but we'll I'll listen to other
people all right thank you very much
anybody other questions see none thank
you okay thank you okay uh Angela Angela
Cuts okay now I got some
cards all
right yes press the press the go okay
good afternoon chairman um Vice chairman
and members of the Commerce and
consumers affair committee thank you for
the opportunity to provide testimony and
support of HB 1296 which which relates
to coverage of medically necessary
breast Imaging my name is Angelica Kats
and I'm the regional manager of State
policy and advocacy at Susan G colan
keman is the world's leading nonprofit
breast cancer organization representing
the millions of people who have been
diagnosed with breast cancer um to
answer your question from earlier uh we
know that mamography is available to
millions of women as the result of the
Affordable Care Act um 16% however 16%
of individuals will require follow-up
Imaging due to an abnormal mamogram
result and they will face uh hundreds to
thousands of dollars in patient call
sharing for this required Imaging so
that follow-up test is not covered um so
we know the mamography is only the
initial step in the early detection
process um and it's not um you know and
is not able to diagnose the cancer alone
uh a com commission study found that the
out of- pocket cost for patients to be
high for example um this average patient
cost for a mamogram is $234 and for a
breast MRI around
$1,100 we often receive calls and emails
from individuals who are unable to
afford the out of pocket cost for their
recommended breast Imaging without
assistance many will simply delay or
foro these medically necessary tests
this delay can mean that patients will
not see care until the cancer has spread
making it much more deadly deadlier and
much more costly to treat and we know
that breast cancer can be up to five
times more expensive to treat when it
has spread beyond the breast to other
parts of the body um so simply put this
is a cost savings bill that will save
the cost not only for the patients but
also for the overall New Hampshire
Health Care System I'd like to share a
story from a patient who came to us
after uh she decided not to get the
diagnostic test because of an $80 co-pay
she said that $80 might as well have
been $88,000 she was a single mother
trying to make ends meet um until one
day her cat had jumped onto her chest
and she was in so much pain she decided
to take out a payday loan which ended up
being more costly than the initial
$80 um just so she can get the
diagnostic test and then she was
unfortunately diagnosed with breast
cancer um and because of her late stage
diagnosis she had to receive chemo and
radiation as well as surgery um to
remove both of her her breast uh if she
was able to afford the diagnostic test
earlier her physician said she may not
have needed the surgery and may not have
lost her breast and her treatment
overall would have been less costly
stories like this one are not uncommon
um you know as you know uh as the
representative uh mentioned earlier uh
you know uh talking um sorry to switch
to the financial lens the study was done
in Massachusetts that uh showed that
this bill would have a negligible impact
on members insurance premiums found that
the typical members monthly health
insurance premium to be between 19 cents
to 33 cents per member per month or
between 03 to six 0 6% of the premium um
you know I like to say that's you know
basically the price of a small coffee
per year um and also this bill will help
breast cancer survivors who need to go
for routine follow-up Imaging so it's
not just um you know for an a diagnosis
early on but also for continuing um care
for Survivor as well uh you know as
committed Partners in the fight against
bre breast cancer we know how deeply
important it is for all cancer patients
to have fair and Equitable access to
breast Imaging um that may save their
lives so we urge you to support hb1 1296
and pass this critical legislation um as
mentioned 20 other states have already
passed it and New Hampshire should be
the next one thank you for your
time okay questions representative Terry
yes uh thank you um just want to um have
a a broader understanding of um what it
is that you're describing um is it is it
not uncommon
for um for someone to have multiple
additional uh imagings like so you have
the mammogram then you might need one
then you might need a second one then
you might need a third one so is it
typical is it is it not on uncommon to
have more than one followup Imaging and
then the second question is um we just
start with that one okay sure um so I
will say we do have a physician here
today who can answer um that more um
more in depth than I can but um I you
know mography like I said the mography
is really just the tip of the iceberg
and then the follow-up testing about 16%
of patients will fall into that category
who need a followup and um again I'm not
a physican
but it you know it could be likely that
you would need multiple maybe you know
two diagnostic tests a year after that
or um but you can ask her to you know
you can ask her your question as well
fur the question yeah so uh in short
your answer is you believe that it's not
uncommon to have more than one yes okay
so the other question is uh typically
when we are talking about Commercial
Insurance we're talking about a
contracted price so that for for example
a retail price might be like 5,000 and
then when the insurance company uh has a
contract it might be something like
2,000 or 3,000 are we typically talking
about contracted price here with respect
to co-payments and and and and is it is
it typical 8020 like it is with many
insurance plans so that the numbers that
you're giving us are numbers that are
based off of contractual amounts
negotiated between insurance companies
and providers and then that's the
remaining typical co-pay that the uh the
patient has to pay like a 20% yeah I
mean I would I would defer to an
insurance company with that specific
question um I can't speak at length on
it and I can get back to so you have the
numbers but you're not sure how they're
well that's from the study that's I can
share that with you as but you're not
sure how they're derived and you're
suggesting we should ask the insurance
companies about how those number how how
those numbers were arrived
at no I'm I'm well no we have the study
I can share that with you but I don't I
don't have the answer for you off the
top of my head but I'm happy to follow
up with you after so you have the cost
but you're not sure how they were
arrived at question those are the cost
just clarifying okay but I I think I got
it you're I think you're right there
you're you're really warm and and I'm
not sure you want to answer this
question but but here's what I think the
question is yep so what we're asking
right now we know that mammographies are
covered yeah with no co-pays or
deductibles but if you are actually
dignosed or the second yes now all of a
sudden the patients co-pays and
deductibles of their plan kicks in so if
you're an employee with a very high
deductible plan right well that's the
one who's paying the, because for all
intensive purposes they're paying the
whole thing so here's my question MH
isn't this true for all cancers yes but
I will say this um doesn't include the
deductibles so that part you don't need
right what I'm saying yes this is
basically saying if you're diagnosed
with cancer I mean this is It's called
this the Campbell's nose Under the Tent
If you're diagnosed with cancer then o
any other diagnostic tests going forward
those people are going to come in and
say we want that same exemption for
cancer I will I will defer to um the
medical professional but I will say not
all cancers are diagnosed the same it's
different so with breast cancer you can
get detected early um through this
process and you know we know that one
in8 women will get breast cancer so it
is one of the leading um diseases for
women got it all right
representative spear I was going to say
bro us cuz I think our hand up was
before you but I could hear you
commenting over there and now I'm
confused okay uh thank you very much
chairman
you my understanding of what you're
saying is that these costs are
associated with even before you find out
if you have cancer it's not you don't
know that you have cancer yet yeah so
it's not like any other cancer patient
you still don't know all they know is
they have have inconclusive data and you
have some shown some
risks so we're trying to go to the next
step now once you have cancer in I
understanding correct correct then a
whole another thing kicks in right thank
you representative Bros yeah I have a
question because it it says Women's
healthc Care how do men also have this
need yes it's not as um it's not as
common in men but yes this does apply to
men as well and and would it also apply
to say a trans man who has not yet had
um gender gender surgery yes when I say
the word woman um I'm all inclusive with
those who identify as okay so they would
be covered thank you
yes thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much okay I'm
call on Heidi
colls
and
so did I get it right Hy what this is
about is after the first test
every test therea is now susceptible to
high deductibles and
co-pays right good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee I'm for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher Callahan and gartell and I
represent ahip which is America's health
insurance plans
um so to answer your question um my
understanding is that the services that
are being discussed here the um
follow-up um
diagnostic um and other I'm looking for
the language here uh SC followup um
Diagnostic and supplemental breast
examinations
so those would be covered but if you
have
not met your deductible then you would
pay the negotiated contract Ed rate that
the carrier has with the providers of
these services and if you have met your
du deductible or once you've met your
deductible then you would pay a co-pay
or co- Insurance depending on the design
of your plan um so um you are correct
that um one of the concerns that we have
with this bill we we understand the
intention and it's certainly well
intentioned um but to the extent that
um so as you mentioned uh preventative
Services Under the Affordable Care Act
are provided um without any cost sharing
um
but uh Services considered to be non
preventative are um are are allowed to
have cost sharing and um and often do
and so the issue is that if we start
removing cost sharing um from these
types of services those costs need to be
collected from somewhere and so they
will either be collected through
premiums or through other cost sharing
or co-pays associated with other
services um the other thing I was going
to mention um this is uh a bill that
would apply to um the individual and uh
small group and large group um fully
insured plans so it does not apply to um
self-funded plans does not apply to
employers who are out of state um
without brick and mortar here in New
Hampshire
um and as I mentioned earlier today in
testimony um the individual Market is
somewhere around six or so percent of
the all of the insurance markets and the
um small and large group are somewhere
in the 20 to
21% um so uh for example the fully
insured Market here in New Hampshire is
34% so this law would not apply to them
um I did notice that there was no fiscal
note I thought that was interesting um I
don't know if this was sent to the
insurance department or not um also in
terms of the effective date UH 60 days
after passage as you know whenever um we
have mandate review or mandate bills we
at least try to have them have an
effective date if it's the committee's
um inclined to pass a bill to have an
effective date that syncs up with the
start start of the planed year which
would be January
1st
um but you know I guess I would just
reiterate that um
coverage when a plan covers services
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
services are
free straight out of the gate some of
them have no cost share some of them
have cost share and deductibles need to
be
met and I'd be happy to try to answer
any
questions okay repres
spear so the thank you uh the Susan
colan Foundation sent me a
huge analysis of the
cost which I take it to be in substitute
of the uh fiscal note because it has
excruciating detail down to the penny as
to what this costs in Massachusetts and
backup data that shows why it's only 13
to 33 cents
it's probably a better analysis than
I've seen typically in our fiscal notes
so my question is have you received this
information and is there a reason at all
that you can find 20 States who have
agreed with it to be invalid and that
for 13 cents or 33 cents we couldn't
push the premiums up a little tiny bit
so I have not seen that report um and at
the end of the day this is a policy
decision for for legislators to make um
my understanding for example in Maine is
that they considered this leg
legislation they clarified the coverage
um but went ahead with no um they didn't
impose the no cost sharing requirement
um but at the end of the day this is a
policy decision for you to make it's
just um to keep in mind the market share
that this would apply to so often we see
mandates passed and then you know the
insurance department or the carriers or
legislators or somebody get get a
complaint that says we passed this
mandate and I'm still I'm still paying
out of pocket you know I'm still paying
or it's not free or it's not a cost you
know I'm paying a co-pay or whatever the
case may be and it's just to remember
that there is a other markets out there
that this um mandate would not apply to
um and then also to keep in mind that
when you lift um cost sharing from
Services um where the ACA doesn't say no
cost sharing you are going to get other
folks coming in with their mandates as
the chairman was mentioning earlier
other other constituents will come in
and look for cost sharing to be removed
from um other services and it's just at
some point
um you know access to um health
insurance um often starts with is the
premium affordable so and these are you
know again this is going to hit um I'm
not saying the 13 to whatever senses a
lot um but this this is uh the
individual and the small and the
Employers in New Hampshire that are ful
follow one
question further question may
inquire based on the uh cancer uh
statistics New Hampshire has among the
highest cancer rate in the
country uh for breast
cancer that kind of puts it in a class
by itself to me and it affects
my sister lives here and she ended up
with breast cancer at the age of 32 and
lost both breasts because she did not
get it diagnosed early
enough uh it puts it in a class by
itself don't you
think that it has to be looked at in an
environment of who it
impacts and to the extent that this
state is being impacted by this disease
and we should make every every effort to
try and
stop the much more costly effects of
having the women go or the women or
whoever has to go to it and by the way
my husband had to get an MRI and that
was pretty
funny to go through the effects of this
so I I think it puts it in a class by
itself or do you not
think it's a as as I said it's a policy
decision for the committee you make good
points I I don't disagree with what
you're saying I think it's just to be
aware that um once you and you can make
this decision it's obviously up to the
legislature but when you lift the cost
sharing on certain Services um others
are going to come in and look for for
that to um apply to whatever set of
services um is associated with the
Mandate that's important to them and so
um it will eventually like I said those
costs have to go someplace I'm not
saying that the the the costs that are
cited in the study are going to be a big
impact but it could have a cumulative
effect so representative Amon thank you
Mr chair thank you for coming and giving
your testimony um I'm trying to think
about this in terms of how free market
forces operate um so mandate is
obviously uh a legislative prescription
and it shifts the costs from a a large
group of rate payers of policy uh payers
to a small group so there there is a
cost but it's dispersed um but as far as
the insurance company's calculation on
if a person stays alive longer they can
pay premiums longer right there's an
incentive for keeping patients alive
what kind of calculation do insurance
companies do that if there is a
preventative uh care that can save money
down the road because it prevents the
spread of cancer to other parts of the
body uh you know more severe damage how
how does that uh factored in in your in
your profit calculations right um if you
could explain
that so I'm not sure that insurance
companies are looking at the lifespan
and how long people are going to um pay
premiums I would say that insurance
companies absolutely want to keep people
healthy and you know um pay for services
that are less expensive that are going
to keep people healthier so that we
avoid um people getting sicker and
people having more costly care um and so
absolutely I don't I don't dis I don't
think any carrier would disagree with
trying to keep people healthy at the end
of the day um this is in part boils down
to benefit design and so the other thing
I would say is that um you know
different different carriers offer
different plans with different
um you know it's a it's a it's a
balancing act right you can have um
lower lower premiums and higher co-pays
or you can have higher premiums and
lower co-pays and so um there there is
some Choice out in the marketplace as
well for people especially in the
individual Market um with deciding
what's what they can afford where they
want to whether they want to pay higher
premiums and lower co-pays or vice versa
um so is there's that choice too but no
I absolutely agree with you that um at
the end of the day we're trying to keep
people healthy and this is a policy
decision
so representative
s so this is kind of a followup um this
is now what the second Bill we've heard
in today that the same argument has been
made that if we do this this will lead
to lower cost savings
for you know because we're it's
preventative the last one was about
glucose monitoring and now we're talking
about breast cancer um
so does anybody in this room has anybody
actually studied this or are people just
saying it because if you know I hear a
lot of numbers maybe it's in this report
which I don't think I've I received but
I'm wondering if anybody's actually
looking looked into this to kind of be
able to provide some insight because
it's been spouted but nobody shared
anything with this committee that I'm
aware of aside from asserting something
and I would love to just see that I'm
not saying that we should be making
decisions based on a cost benefit
analysis of a life but if that's going
to be part of the argument of why we
should Implement something then I would
like to see some of the evidence behind
it and so this is sort of a if you have
it I'd love to share it if you're the
people that you represent have it or
some of the other people who have
testified have it I would love to get my
hands on it so I can dig into it sort of
would you believe I guess
um I can see what we we have on that
front I
think there are probably you know
benefits down the road by you know doing
something earlier and and preventing
something more costly down the road um
so there's the time factor in here as
well but you know at least in the early
part of this you would have the cost
being shifted from from the smaller
population to the premium payers
um without the immediate benefits I
guess so uh represent selvan and I I'll
I'll I haven't we haven't done it in a
long time actually since Pam sming so
I'll have it done but the list all the
health insurance
mandates and I have to admit that the
Lion Share literally almost 90% happened
while I was here so but and and I say
this on that I've never met a health
insurance mandate that we've gotten and
we have like 30 40 of them that the
premise always was that this is better
long-term consequently longterm everyone
that's that's always a premise and
what's the reason we have it okay now
this one is a little unusual uh this
one's very different to me first of all
uh I've never seen a billing where the
definitions are secondary to the actual
structure of a lot it's kind of upside
down but not withstanding that I'm I'm
working my way through this and I guess
I way I read it this is a onot
deal it you know in terms of that you
you some woman's had a mography and and
then and or had or actually says based
on personal family history that words if
you have breast cancer in your personal
family that you can request to have
this um I guess it's more uh I assume
it's the you know the the the high
definition the 3D uh machine doing the
the breast exam um and but I I'm not
sure how many times you can ask for it
how many times it does it's not clear
whether this is multiple so I'm you know
when you say state of Massachusetts only
has 131 19 cents but it it appears maybe
that was it was a one-hot deal and you
get this done and then uh and through
ically you don't need to do it again I
don't know I don't how that works but
I'm intrigued when you said that Maine
narrowed it with did they they remove
the cost sharing requirements or what
did they how did they narrow it so this
is subject to check but my understanding
is that Maine had a similar piece of
legislation they they ended up I think
subject to check clarifying about the
coverage of um Diagnostic and
supplemental breast examinations so
ensuring that those would be covered but
they did not move forward with the idea
that it would that there would um they
impose any you know they can't impose
any cost sharing requirements they they
didn't go so they said do that they said
yes you can have but they did pick up
this language here where someone could
ask for it based on their family history
for instance uh that part I don't know
I'd have to double check so okay now
because in New Hampshire we give you one
free mon me a year and I know one time
we had a debate whether that was a year
at a day or you know that was one of our
debated issues um so so in this case
this this is um again the narrowed in
what the idea of this is is that um it
would remove any cost
sharing from the bill which obviously I
mean that people with a high deductible
plan that says a lot of money if someone
doesn't have a high deductible plan that
saves some
money got it right and the other thing I
would say
um you know I think it's important to
make sure that the um the definitions
that are given in here I mean medical
necessity always applies even in the
cases of mandates um that we're follow
following you know um medical necessity
guidelines and so those guidelines are
continuously evolving um we had to
discuss discussion about those this
morning in terms of um the carriers you
know have independent panels that look
to
um National um experts and professionals
who um always are uh upgrading whatever
the
um best practices are so um I think we
just want to make sure um that we're not
putting anything in the um in the
definitions that would kind of lock in
whereas we we really do want Medical
necessity to be able to evolve with the
expert opinions that are out
there okay great thank you now um there
was some comment there's a physician I
don't see any but who who Who's The
Physician so your name is come okay come
on up
Eva
good
afternoon hello can you hear me yes we
can great um so I've submitted some
written uh testimony online and there's
a copy of it going
around um I thought I might sort of mix
it up because there were a lot of
questions which I I might be the only
one in the room who's able to
answer um that'd be great
okay so my name is Dr Eva lier I am a
Subs specialty Fellowship trained breast
Imaging radiologist I've been in
practice for 14 years uh most recently
at my own clinic in
Lee uh the scope of the problem I think
has been discussed um we recommend that
screening mammograms I I think there's
some confusion between screening
mammograms and diagnostic mammograms
tomosynthesis 2D
mammograms um so we recommend screening
mammograms for women beginning at age 40
annually which as we've discussed here
are um free without cost sharing to
insure patients everything else after
that is not free and it goes towards
your deductible your co-pay um I'm now a
small business owner myself so I can
talk all sorts of business about trying
to go onto the individual Market or
getting health insurance for my
employees and there were very few plans
that were actually not high deductible
that were available to us um so just to
go through some of the questions um I
don't know of any facilities in our area
in this this part of the state
um maybe throughout the state that don't
do Tomo synthesis everything now is 2D
3D so um everything is 2D 3D um
screening is free diagnostic mammograms
are mammograms um so when you come in if
a thousand women have a screening
mamogram today in New Hampshire about a
hundred of those women will be called
back for an abnormality so everything
from that point for those 100 women is
not free that's what goes towards the
cost sharing um it could be an
ultrasound you know maybe a few hundred
a diagnostic mammogram is frequently
over
$600 um could be as much as a thousand
um could be an MRI could be a
biopsy uh it happens really frequently
that we're just not sure sure enough to
Warrant a biopsy and so we recommend
follow-up Imaging in 3 months or 6
months so it's just a multi-step process
and it is that way every year you
know um what
else so how when when you when you've
been diagnosed yeah how many times would
you come back to get another screening
it might be just once um so say you have
a an abnormality on your screening
mamogram um you'll be called back
for usually it's a diagnostic mamogram
plus an ultrasound and then a
biopsy um and then an
MRI and for every breast cancer
diagnosis you're pretty much going to
get the MRI which is around
$2500 um and those are those are you
know we talked about the the contract
price might be $5,000 and it gets
negotiated down depending on your pair
um so that happens with everybody and
then you go to surgery and after you
have your breast cancer diagnosis you
get put into the diagnostic pool for two
to five years afterwards so you don't
have a screening mamogram after that you
have a diagnostic mamogram every six
months and that's the one that's 600
bucks so and that's just how it's done
right well you get you still get a free
one every year not not after oh once
you've actually
been that's interesting no you're not
considered um this is a medical term but
not really medical we call you
walkie-talkie so you're walkie-talkie
off the street normal no problems you
get a screening mamogram if you have a
single problem we say no you're a
diagnostic mamogram and the diagnostic
mamogram is just more tailored exam of
each breast and so it's read Real Time
by someone like myself who's able to say
I'm not really sure about this spot can
you go back in and do some extra
pictures and we're going to need an
ultrasound it's really a work in
progress exam so that's why I diagnos
mamams are more
expensive yeah and and that's true I I
would imagine um I mean it goes from
like up to five years women will be in
the diagnostic
pool so um I think that was something
mentioned about
um it was representative spear who was
talking about the prevalence of breast
cancer in our state which is absolutely
true I've had to do statistics on this
before um we're routinely in the top
five I think the most recent Year we're
number four out of 50 states whatever it
is here we have a lot of breast cancer
across the United States it's one in
eight women um I'm sorry one in eight
women yeah will be diagnosed with
invasive breast cancer that's the kind
that can metastasize to lungs liver
brain bones um but here in New Hampshire
it's a little bit higher unfortunately
so we see a lot of it and also is one of
the few cancers where we screen manually
so you could be like I said
walkie-talkie off the street totally
normal every year but maybe you have a
lot of benign breast disease you know
masses are constantly forming in your
breasts that are benign not cancer but
we don't know until we take a look at
them further so that's why you know if a
th000 mammograms are done today 100
women will be called back not all of
it's cancer maybe only 10 of those are
cancer um I think that was it on the oh
and I did there was a question um that
came up about the fiscal note and I
remember uh there was an email about the
um the insurance department did get a
copy of this and they did not oppose
this bill um they said it wouldn't defil
if I'm getting that word right they
wouldn't defil the costs because there
are no new Services being
added if that makes sense um it's just
expansion right so existing Services
that's an issue related to Affordable
Care Act that if we were to create a
whole if this wasn't already being
done then uh the state would have to pay
for the Mandate okay uh but that in
terms of what the insurance department
they don't take positions on
mandates regardless so but that they
would say to us that we if in terms of
doing it we have a a statute to do a
cost analysis on the Mandate okay on the
bill so right because these are services
that we been doing for decades this is
this is not anything that's that would
be new or experimental right exactly um
and I did want to mention there was
something to that came up about non-
preventative care um this is something
that I talked to my patients a lot about
more recently because of some federal
legislation um we've been talking more
about dense breasts and how mammograms
are not very Sensi screening mammograms
are not very sensitive in dense breast
tissue if mammograms are maybe 80 %
sensitive in all Commerce it could go
down to 60% in women with extremely
dense breasts so what we recommend is an
ultrasound if you're of average risk and
that would be annually um just to make
sure you know that that finds maybe
three additional cancers per thousand
and um for women who are at higher risk
annual
MRI whether they're dense or not but if
you have enough of a family history and
this is all truly what a physician like
myself would consider preventative care
because what we're trying to present
prevent is metastatic breast cancer
because there's no cure for that you
know we can cut out little cancers and
we can irradiate them and it's cheap to
do so I mean relatively cheap what's
really expensive as when you take a
working woman off the streets and you
know sideline her so that she can't work
anymore she can't provide child care
elder
care so just um maybe it's l so but an
ultrasound is going to be cheaper than
an
MRI Lots that's what I yes I would think
so uh maybe 250 $250 old technology
versus new exactly yeah yeah okay um I
thought I would give a couple of
examples 10 days ago I received a call
at my office in the morning I think it
was that day that was really snowy
whatever that day was and it was a woman
who lived out of State she was calling
about her mom who uh she had just found
out that her mom had a breast
MK and so she said how can I get her in
she doesn't have a doctor she doesn't go
to the doctor routinely and I asked if
she did have insurance and she said yes
she has you know something so she works
in
manufacturing and um so we finally got
this woman in she went to Urgent Care
and I got a call from the Urgent Care PA
never a good sign and said it's you're
going to need to biopsy this so I'm
sending over orders right now as well
and the woman had a breast mask that um
it was as hard as this table and my
staff who's like they're highly trained
highly experienced they said I don't
know how you're going to biopsy that
because it was so hard so I did and it
was a struggle and I biopsy the lymph
nodes under her arm and unfortunately I
also biopsy lymph nodes under the other
arm because the cancer had become so
widespread that it moved clear on over
to the other side so that's a kind kind
of thing that we're trying to prevent
and I've seen this so many times and
it's so frustrating and it I remember
the first time that I had a conversation
with a patient about insurance and what
exams would cost and it was oh gosh I
was so awkward about it I was probably
practicing for three or four years it
was like you know
2012 and um I just tripped all over
myself but I do it all the time now so
I'm really good about it they're always
asking what's it going to cost how much
is a biopsy versus like what if I come
back in six months and you just ult down
this again like making these decisions
just rationalizing stuff all the time
they don't come back for follow-up care
that we recommend because they're
worried about the cost they get the
first bill and then they don't want to
come back so they stretch it out for 12
months and then they're just worried the
whole time and you see that sigh of
relief when you come back in they're
like oh it's the same oh thank goodness
it's just kind of crazy it's not what I
expected when I went to
Breast Care or medical
school uh represented
bam I've experienced
many um uh I had to go into the to be
diagnosed several times every time I
would go in and uh it hasn't happened
since I am on Social Security now so I
don't know if that makes a difference or
another or are the machines better than
they were 20 years ago because I always
had to be called back and now I don't my
mother died of breast cancer when she
was 60
so is there like a different hospitals
have different machines or are all the
machines the same can I trust the person
that does you know the um Diagnostics um
can I trust her so the machines are all
pretty similar these days but there was
a Great Leap Forward with Tomas
synthesis back in 20
3 um I would say that as a woman ages
cancer becomes more uh more common you
know our our sort of annual risk for
cancer increases but it's a lot easier
to diagnose it in an older woman um the
breast sort of quiet down there are a
bunch of things that happen in breast
tissue in younger women that tend not to
happen in older women and so you have
less confounding stuff going on We There
are some women who get called back every
year because they have cysts or they
have other you know calcifications
forming and things like that and we
can't tell just based off of a screening
mammogram because it truly is only the
beginning we cannot tell what it is we
have to get you back in it's it's always
just multiple steps in the
process all right
thanks okay thank you very much oh
represent Terry so it's it's generally
recognized that uh women are far more
conscientious about taking care of
themselves than men and are far less in
denial about needing to do things to
take care of themselves so I just wanted
to be uh sure about
that uh really really D treading on and
that is and that is that you when you're
saying that there are women who are
concerned about the cost in terms of
coming back for additional Imaging that
that that that's the vast majority if
not all of the cases uh because I'm
sitting is a man saying well you know if
it was a man he would he would just deny
it and it wouldn't be anything to do
with money so is it's it's it's pretty
much the money right it's a a financial
hardship there are a lot of barriers to
healthc care I mean you try scheduling
your mammogram right now it's going to
be three months right like it's really
hard to get a hold of anybody on the
phone there are a lot of barriers but I
will disagree with you politely and say
that um the things that I hear in my
exam rooms are it's hard to get time off
work to come in for testing it's hard to
get child care um when I give a woman a
diagnosis of breast cancer within the
first five minutes they're talking about
who's going to take care of EX you know
they're worried about their husbands if
they're older they're worried about
their kids if they're younger I see a
lot of women who put off things you know
there's like this whole uh wellness and
self-care culture sure um you can ask
any physician we like the last ones to
participate in Wellness or self-care cuz
we're like go go go but um a lot of
women are that way they a lot of women
will put things off just because they
feel that they don't have time and
they're worried about
costs so I do I just truly have so many
questions about uh cost now that I have
a printed out copy of our self-pay uh
self-pay costs like $800 for a biopsy
you know like I can quote some of them
off the top of my head because I get
asked so often rck
fall thank you yes so thank you for
clarifying that that it's not denial
it's it's all sorts of
concerns that that that women have and
it it includes Financial but it's it's a
number of other concerns like who's
going to take care of my children yada a
whole bunch of concerns y okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome thank you very much
much okay uh chair we'll call on Peter
bragon for Harvard
Pilgrim with his
concerns thank you Mr chairman committee
members again Peter Bron uh representing
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare the state's
only KN for profit health insurance
carrier for the individual and group
markets and uh I specifically indicated
on this as well as the prior bill that
we are not taking a position for or
against but wanted to just raise some
issues around it for your consideration
and having been a former legislator I
can appreciate the position where uh
it's not necessarily black and white
there's it's a balancing act that that
has to occur and so I just like to
address a few things on that uh first of
all uh the prior Bill we had today uh
had major concerns with regarding the
fact that it took out the medical
necessity and had no cost sharing I will
point out that this bill appears to me
that uh on lines 18 and
24 uh does include the term medically
necessary so it doesn't have the same
issues that uh this morning's Bill had
uh and so the the issue then revolves
around the the no cost sharing provision
therein um and as I mentioned earlier
there are several bills uh coming down
the pike this year and there are several
every year that try to eliminate cost
sharing and that's where that balancing
test comes in um and one final note
before I mention the cost sharing U my
understanding understanding is that the
state of Maine has legislation that it
has enacted legislation that is very
similar to this um to my understanding
the state of Massachusetts had not they
had legislation before them which
generated I think the cost study that uh
you have seen we have not seen that but
I think that's what's being referred to
and they sent it off to study so just
that that's my knowledge of it as we
were here I was texting uh my contact at
Harvard Pilgrim to say what's going on
in these other states so that's
currently my understanding if that
changes I'll let you know um but the
whole issue of the cost sharing it's a
balancing act right because costs will
get shifted whether they're small cost
or larger cost it's a range of them and
so um what's going to happen is if you C
if if you make it so any specific
disease or condition does not have cost
sharing that means others who have other
diseases are going to have to that the
cost is going to get shifted to them and
then some of those people may foro their
treatment or a company who is providing
insurance for their employees may see
the cost increase for the plan they have
and decide okay I'm going to shift to a
plan with a higher deductible at which
point their employees are faced with
this decision of should I get care or
shouldn't I right it's a factor that
everybody comes into and some companies
may decide I'm not going to provide
insurance for my employees at all at
which point they have to get their own
some of them will choose not to get it
uh and some will get high deductible
plans and some will be forced to make
that decision so in any of these things
whether it's the breast cancer screening
or the glucose
monitoring some group will have an
easier time but it's a balancing act
because there's going to be other people
who may either not have insurance at all
or be faced with decisions on other
diseases uh chronic or acute that uh
they have to make that same decision so
it's a balancing act on a policy uh set
and so uh we're not taking a position on
the policy itself but just the big
picture idea that cost sharing
eliminating cost sharing by itself it's
not an isolated incident it affects
other parts of the system and again
we're not not for-profit uh insurance
company we're not looking to protect
shareholders but we do want to make sure
that people as many people as possible
can have insurance and you're in a
difficult position happy to answer any
questions represent
carry good enough good enough anything
but late for
dinner
I don't want to be left with the
impression that we're talking about an
increase in uh premiums of hundreds of
dollars the analysis which I have a copy
of and I I guess you may have we're
talking about 13 to 33
cents let's put it in the right ballpark
if we're going to say well we're going
to push up premiums we're going to do
this is we're talking about pennies and
we're talking about one of the highest
cancer rates in the country affecting so
many people so I think when you give
these kinds of statements I think you
got to put them in proportion thank you
for the question and I I didn't mean to
uh imply that it's a range of things
this one as compared to the glucose
monitoring earlier the day this is very
small uh the invitro fertilization which
was $10 to $100 per member per month
that's that's on way on the other scale
so but it's still a balance act and yes
it's going to be now I don't know what
that Massachusetts law said I don't know
who did the study I don't know what
assumptions were made but even let's
assume it's you know 33 cents per month
so it's uh uh four bucks basically per
employee per year you got 100 employees
so your insurance premium is going to go
up $400 in addition to what it's already
going up right and so a company may look
at that and say I can absorb that a
company may look at it and say okay
given all the other increases uh in our
profits this year I'm going to raise the
deductible so I I do think this on on
the it's on the small scale of things
being looked at but the same Balancing
Act applies things things are not
static right thank you very much thank
you okay
uh Carrie Becker had a question oh who
who has do you have a question sure
sorry do we know the compar comparison
from men to women um are there um cancer
rates much different that is not thank
you for the question that is not
something I I would know about perhaps
there's people uh who will speak on this
that know more about that than I do uh
and I'll repeat by the way what I saw on
the other way that notice that the state
employees are not included town and
School Employees so it's again passing a
bill that applies to other people but
not to the government only to 20% of the
population thank
you okay Carrie
Baker back
be okay
Becker everyone awake
now thank you Mr chairman and thank you
everyone I am Carrie Becker I uploaded a
statement on through the website
yesterday I am one of your one and
eight okay I live in Northampton New
Hampshire
[Music]
and I'm going to stray a little bit from
this I'm asking you to support how
Hospital
1296 I was diagnosed at the age of 46
back in 2021 February with invasive
decal cancer breast cancer but I caught
it early the diagnostic piece is great
you you know ACA gives us the
opportunity to get a mammogram and the
costs are nothing to us but after I had
that mamogram I had three ultrasounds
two biopsies one MRI and
three additional mammograms I had to pay
for that out of
pocket okay so you want to talk about
cost sharing I'm very fortunate I able
to afford that I'm the mom of two boys
my husband owns a business in New
Hampshire
and there have been two three four women
diagnosed in the past three years at his
company here in New Hampshire with
breast
cancer one of which who has
died
this is it's it is detectable I caught
it early enough I'm St I was stage two
and I will be in a
diagnostic bucket for five to 10 years
so until I'm almost
60 so think about it I mean that's that
means that now my mammograms are no
longer coded as preventative it is cated
as
diagnostic so being diagnostic that
means that I might have to go do another
breast
MRI it means that I actually I I pay
more just to make sure that I'm living
the life as they call it the Ned life no
evidence of
disease um I know another woman who and
and forgive me I might end up in tears
another woman decided instead of going
back after having an abnormal
mamogram and going and doing more
diagnostic testing she decided to pay
for her child's education college
education she
died women will do things for their
family and for other people we are
caregivers instead of taking care of
ourselves oh it just hurts it'll be okay
I'll figure it out oh I went I go
annually it's not a big
deal all I'm asking is from some
recognition that hey you know what I am
living right now with no evidence of
disease but I shouldn't be
penalized and have to pay more to make
sure I stay that
way that's that's what I'm asking for
I'm not saying that we should have
preferential treatment I'm saying I want
to live for my
boys I want to be
around I am lucky I am very fortunate to
be able to afford the out of pocket
costs but think about the people who
don't I have friends who still haven't
gotten mammograms and they're
they know
me we caught it early it was my fourth
annual mammogram that they found
it
um it's an emotional
toll it is scary and every year that I
go have my screening which I will have
in February it's scary it's a lot yes
thank you thank you so much it is it's
scary it's it I walk in going going are
they going to find something because
when you say one and eight it's one and
eight in each breast it doesn't
jump I had a mastectomy I had radiation
I am in chemical menopause so I have to
take medicine all the
time it's not I wouldn't wish this on my
worst
enemy but diagnostic testing saved saved
my life the tumor they grew within a
year grew they were three
cmers from zero to 3 centimeters I had
multiple places and
um it was invasive ductal carcinoma
which is the scary piece but I'm I am
living the Ned life and that's I'm just
asking for your support because
diagnostic I understand there is a
profit piece to healthcare and things
like that and insurance and somebody has
to take the costs but if you have people
who are diagnosed with breast cancer
working being a part and being
productive in society and giving back
and and and and increasing the economy
by purchasing and doing things then
isn't that a win for
everyone is that what we're looking
for I can I can talk I I don't have
numbers I know that because of the
diagnosis for a lot of the spouses uh my
husband's company which is based out of
Bedford New Hampshire employs 160
people their insurance premiums went up
300% because of it yet they swallow the
cost the company does they don't pass it
on to the employees because they care
about the employees because they want
people to
work it's I don't know I'm just asking
you to really consider this and think
about it think about who's impacted one
in eight you may not know someone who
has you
may but it's much more
common thank
you thank you for
sharing thank you very
much okay got one card left mik
Rolo
yeah oh yeah Diane yeah I know I know I
knew his mother oh I did too
yeah no the whole Rollo
family
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Michael Rolo and I have the
honor privilege of being the government
relations director for the American
Cancer Society cancer Action Network
here in New Hampshire and we are here in
support of uh strong support of House
Bill
1296 and I am not going to uh do much
with my testimony now because I don't
think I need to I think you definitely
understand the difference
between a
screening M mamogram at this point and
why uh some women um and Men um may need
to go for a follow-up
exam uh just this morning the American
Cancer Society released its annual uh
cancer facts and Figures it's very
timely that it was released just
today and um we have new
numbers uh estimated numbers of how many
people will be diagnosed with cancer in
the state of New
Hampshire the new grand total
approximately will be
9,880 people that number has gone up
unfortunately for breast cancer it is
1,460 women will approximately be
diagnosed in the year 2024 with breast
cancer now men can also be diagnosed
with breast cancer uh the Cancer Society
does not track uh that number uh by
state it is uh not a a a number that's
large enough to be tracked in men but it
is it is it does happen for men um of
that
1,460 women approximately 180 of them
will lose their
life to breast cancer in the state of
New Hampshire in 200 24 it's rather
sobering number 180 women will lose
their life to breast cancer in the state
of New
Hampshire cost sharing can be a barrier
to people getting follow-up
care and I think you just heard rather
emotional testimony an important
testimony as to why it was
important for her to get additional
Diagnostic and follow-up care not
everyone has the ability to
go and get that
care we would argue that it's important
for them to be able to access that care
and that the 180 lives that may be lost
in the state of New Hampshire this year
are important and God forbid any of them
lose their life because they couldn't
afford followup care I don't want that
on my conscience personally and 20 other
states in this Union have decided they
don't want it on their conscience either
States including the liberal bastions of
Texas and Louisiana and
Tennessee um New York I'll give you
Illinois I mean it's across the Spectrum
this is not a red state blue State thing
this is uh States understanding that
there are this is a real issue for their
constituents and that they want to take
action and that costs can be a barrier
to preventative care and that that they
wanted to take action on that L there 20
States that's an impressive number this
is not uh New Hampshire going out on a
limb the Cancer Society sees this as a
Continuum you know when you go in for
that initial screening and if you need a
followup because there's an adality in
in that initial
screening it's a Continuum it's not a
oneand done and you're out the door I
think you just heard from a physician
that you know it's not it's not uncommon
common for her to have to have follow-up
care for some of her patients and those
people deserve just as much care as the
person that came in and was able to get
done and one and done and you know
and my ironically enough my wife
actually had her mamogram
today it's um all the stars were alining
apparently
um she last the last year the year
before last had to have a followup
um doesn't happen every time but she did
have to go she has a family
history
um
um she
um and you know it's fine but um we were
able to cover whatever cost we were
lucky though not everyone is in that
position in every Granite stator
regardless should have the same same
access to to to the same care that that
that my wife had and the same the same
chance of survival if they do catch it
and that's all we're asking is sort of
even the playing field um as they have
done in 20 other states so we' ask you
for your support um again I've got the
written testimony but you don't need to
hear me read it and you've heard more
than enough from from these other folks
so we would ask you to please support uh
House Bill 1296 I'd be happy to answer
any
questions
uh representative
grassy thank you Mr R um I you know when
you take a look at the cost of of cancer
particularly breast cancer and its
emotional impact on families everything
I'm wondering if anybody has ever
calculated out what the cost is because
this is what the insurance companies are
concerned about because it it affects
their premiums what's the cost of
catching breast cancer early or
screenings catch catching breast cancer
only in treatment of early uh detection
as opposed to not catching it early and
having long-term treatment and even
death from breast cancer has the Cancer
Society ever looked at those
costs I believe we
have um I don't have a number to give
you
today I can tell you
that
catching uh a cancer stage one at
beginning stages is much better for the
patient uh more likely to have a better
outcome uh not always but you have a
better chance of survival you have
[Music]
um less resources perhaps
um uh on the system being used um I I I
tend to worry less about that than than
what the actual person has to go through
I know it's important to have to worry
about that but um but there are costs of
course associated with Cancer Care and I
don't have the number at the moment but
um I can look and find out I know that
we have we have looked at that across
the country and I'll see if I can try to
find it for you but I I don't know if we
have the analysis how up to date it is
at the moment but I'll try to find it
for
you representative Ammon thank you Mr
chair thank you for your testim
and your personal uh sharing your
personal stories you mentioned there's
new cancer uh American Cancer Society
data that was released I think you said
yesterday just this morning actually
just this morning yeah I don't know if
you've had a chance to look at those I'm
curious about the progress that we're
making on cancer is it getting worse or
is it getting better um and if it's
getting worse
um I guess I'll have a followup question
for that well it depends so there's that
for an non-an for you right it depends
um it depends on cancer is not one
disease right it's it's hundreds of
diseases so there have been great
breakthroughs and great strides in
certain types of cancers breast cancer
for instance there are there are uh uh
different ways to uh to treat there are
new
therapies
[Music]
um I think of um preventative screenings
that have uh been developed um for uh
for lung cancer recently um there are um
obviously
[Music]
um preventative screenings for colon
cancer where we have um we have worked
very diligently to uh offset uh cost
sharing there as well to make sure that
when you go under I mean I've been
having my uh annual colonoscopy since I
turned 30 because I lost both my father
my uncle and my grandfather colon cancer
so they said you get to go early um so
I've been having them for 20 years now
um so aren't I lucky but um but one time
you would you would go and you'd go
under and you'd wake up and you'd get a
bill you know so some people stopped
going you know so uh because they didn't
want to wake up with that surprise um
but uh we we've made great strides there
so you know but anyway so it depends I'm
sorry we made great strides where people
are going to get tested so you can go
and you get you you you can you can you
can avoid a colon cancer diagnosis by
getting a poop removed I guess is my
point Mr chairman I see your your look
on your face as to why you think well
that's every five years well depends yes
but some people annual so you know when
but repres was asking me about about
cancer rates in general there are
different there are different reasons
why some may go down and some may go up
but So Co for instance had delayed a lot
of people from getting preventative
screenings so we're only a very short
amount of time out of the the the the
Heyday of the pandemic right so we don't
know how what the delayed screenings
will have will mean to to Future uh
cancer rates in in the in the next 5 10
years so it's hard to answer I I should
have narrowed it down to just death
rates from cancer I mean that that would
probably be a harder I think it's it's
unfortunately it's the same rambling
answer I'm sorry
representative okay representative Gibbs
thank you uh in terms of the need for
additional diagnostic tests following
screenings and the additional outof
pocket costs for those additional
diagnostic tests how does breast cancer
compare to other types of cancer as for
instance colon cancer or prostate
cancer can you ask ask me the question
I'm I'm not sure if I'm following
exactly okay um uh there's been a lot of
discussion about how following the
initial screening which is the
mamogram right there if if if there's um
something unusual ual scene and this
happened to me once yeah um then
additional diagnostic tests are are
necessary um and that there are greater
out-of-pocket costs for those additional
diagnostic tests and that what that's
what this bill is supposed to address
right what I'm asking is in terms of the
need for additional diagnostic tests and
the out-of-pocket cost for those tests
after
screening how does breast cancer compare
to other types of cancer well so you you
brought up a prostate um so a PSA test
is not actually covered so so for
instance so mamography isn't covered
like isn't one of the essential health
benefits like uh under the Affordable
Care Act like um PSA isn't covered the
same way that test wasn't included under
the ACA so there is um depending on your
your uh your your individual plan you
may or may not have uh cost sharing
there I guess I don't my plan doesn't
have any so I all I can speak is from my
personal experience with PSA testing uh
there
um I don't think they they're not um
you're not talking apples to apples
unfortunately I don't think
so there aren't um I think there are
additional there would be more C sharing
with a breast diagnosis a breast cancer
cancer diagnosis than with others as far
as I'm aware
of actually I want to pick up there yes
sir uh tell me a a cheap cancer I don't
think there is one exactly so the only
reason why this bill wouldn't you say
the only reason this bill is here is
because these test machines are so damn
expensive right the colon now let's say
the you know the prostate is you know
you say you know that they were don't
really have a has but let's there a test
it's a blood test for for PSA test BL
test but when you have the actual
surgery MH or you actually like let's
take much more dramatic cancers like
esophageal or colon cancers where you've
got to take some pretty serious
drugs and they're really expensive
MH what's the difference between an
expensive drug treatment plan okay and
this
bill what's the difference between being
having already being diagnosed having
cancer and going on a drug versus a
preventative screening test well no the
preventative you don't have to get there
oh no no that's only one test okay but
then the rest of your life You' got to
have these this preventative so-called
preventative but we just heard that you
don't get cheap you don't get the cheap
affordable onetime
test I did not hear that this test is on
only a onetime
test I heard is that you can get it you
would pretty much want to do this
annually once you've been diagnosed with
cancer so I'm just saying where's the
cheap cancer I think what I think you
may
be perhaps misunderstanding what the
doctor may have said I think what she
said if you have been diagnosed right
with breast cancer correct then you were
in in a different category right and you
would go back and get the same
test it's different you going go back
and get the cheap mamography test no
you're in a different category because
you've now had cancer and you you're
you're you you're no you're you're
tested in a different way you you can
come back up and explain it to you I'm
talking about the cost of this machine
the reason why this bill is in here
which machine
this what are you calling this machine
the 3D mamography machine 3D scan the 3D
scanner whatever okay so here here's
what I'm saying any cancer is
expensive when we well we hear today
this Tes to treat if you have to treat
it exactly so what we have here in terms
of when you have been diagnosed uhhuh
okay because you you you flunk the
original test right okay now you're
going to go in and now they're going to
charge you $2,000 for the same test
different no it's
not that's what she's been trying she
tried to explain to you she could
probably come back up and explain it is
it a different I can see her is it the
it's the same diagnostic you're
diagnostic whether you're still have the
tumors or still have pups or whatever
whatever you still have stuff in there
right
and maybe the doctor should come back up
and explain he's right there so you're
you uh
when you've been diagnosed with breast
cancer so we call a diagnostic mamogram
any mamogram that is not a screening
mamogram and a screening mamogram is
only for women who have no symptoms no
active breast cancer it's the same
machine the pictures are different right
the pictures are are more tailored to
the problem and the examination is read
real time so that's what a diagnostic H
but you still you'll never do it again
so when you've had breast cancer for a
recent breast cancer diagnosis if you
were diagnosed with breast cancer in
2021 right you will be asked to return
as a diagnostic mamogram patient not a
screening mamogram patient for years
while we watch your breast more closely
to make sure that the cancer doesn't
return and Screen the opposite side but
to get rid of that
cancer you had to pay take expensive
drugs right not always
you mean there's a cheap cancer drug out
there so well you don't always need
drugs for a breast cancer sometimes it's
just surgery just the remove just the
removal okay and so then for the the one
you go back a year later you're just
going to get the cheap the the one the
the the the test that's covered free no
you're still going to have to pay for it
yeah that's what I'm talking about if
you've had if you've had breast cancer
if you were diagnosed this year for um
it say
you know 2024 with breast cancer
diagnosis you were treated entirely in
2024 you would be in a diagnostic
mamogram category for two years five
years and how much is that test so that
test is yeah $1,000 could be depending
on the facility you go to and you're in
you're out okay okay thank you so I I do
have I do understand the situation the
reason I'm trying to describe this to
you
Ry the reason why I'm going through this
with you Ry is that you represent cancer
right
so and I think we've had bills before in
the past on cancer bills sure my fear is
that if we pass this legislation uhuh
with no deductibles we said okay we're
going to we're going to get rid of the
deductibles what other Cancer Treatments
this is this is supplemental screening
uh it's screening okay but the screening
every year it's a annual screening yes
not the same as for people that have
been diagnosed
I'm may I ask a question representative
Gibs thank
you is the diagnostic mamogram that the
patient will have to have perhaps every
year for years after the problem has
been found is that can I finish my
question is that more expensive than the
regular screening mamogram that someone
gets is it is it notably more expensive
as far as I know yes but it's different
than what this
is I'm all done it's not the same thing
though I'm all done I'm I'm all I'm all
set I got it are we debating here yeah
exactly apparently we are but it's not
the same thing I I I'm totally wrong I
have no idea what I'm talking about I'm
not suggesting I have no fear that no
other cancer bill is going to come in
and say we want to be be deductible free
for
screenings I who knows what it is it's
cancer cancer is a bad thing don't you
think well yes I do think cancer is a
bad thing and I think it's very
important that people get preventative
screenings but I don't think it's a joke
I'm uh this is not a joke I don't think
it is either but I think it's being I
think I'm being spoken to like it is I
am very sorry if you feel that way I was
being very serious I don't think you
were Mr chairman I've known you for
almost 30 years I don't think you
were it's thank you very much and I have
a great deal of respect for you I truly
do but I know when you're joking with me
thank you very much thank
you I have no other cards so I will
close the public
hearing
oh okay Representative Steve Boer wants
to
testify yes
Steve
thank you um I've been sitting here
listening and I was holding the card to
last because I didn't
realize I didn't want to waste your time
going over the same thing over and over
again but it occurred to me that we're
missing I think we're overlooking what
the bill was attempting to
do what this bill is doing is when a a
lady goes in a woman goes in and has a
test they find in this test a dark
spot so then after they get the little
letter in the mail saying we've seen a
dark
spot we recommend you to go and have
another look
see so now the woman has to make a
second appointment for another test
test there has been no
Diagnostics done there's nothing done
other than the fact that they now have
to go have this secondary
test this secondary test comes out of
their
pocket because it falls in the
deductible
so they go and take this test they still
don't know what they
have the test is
done they then determine is there
something more has to be done after the
secondary
test still no diagnostic they still not
been said they had cancer and there's a
high probability they do not have
cancer they just have an ABM
morality so if they go for that third
test once again it becomes out of that
high
deductibility at that point this third
test says yes you have
cancer so at that point it switches from
this
plan to now you're diagnosed with cancer
you fall under your 8020 or your 75
whatever it is 6040 plan portion because
to get to that point you've already
burned up your high deductibility just
paying for the tests to figure out do I
even have a
problem so when one's saying oh you've
got cancer way up here no we're not
talking about cancer way up here we're
just talking out trying to figure out a
plan plan to figure out what's
wrong and what this Bill is saying is
please allow this
person to be able to get through a B to
C to figure out what it is because a
majority of the time after they've been
to
be they found out there's no other issue
then they go back into normal Cycles of
doing their testing whereas if they have
to go to C and they're diagnosed then
yes they're put in a special category
which then says you have to have your
screening and it's not deductible so as
trying to separate the two together this
bill is only trying to address a and b
not C doesn't say if I have cancer now I
want you to pay for it all it's saying
is
I want to be able to have this test
where the first one is the
screen that says oh you got the spot we
don't know what the spot
is and then B that's where they do a
finer Point as the doctor said they do
the finer points of things to make the
determination is it cancer we still
don't know until they've done that and
this bill is only Happ asking that that
portion up until
diagnos until it's been
diagnosed is covered as part of your
free mamogram that's what it's trying to
accomplish representative grassy has a
question so if I'm understanding this
correctly based on all of the comments
were made previously you're saying once
a person has been
diagnosed these treatments are no longer
diagnostic they're now part of the
treatment that that's correct thank you
and that follows that path C it would go
under the insurance plan that goes under
the insurance
plan
correct that's in layman's term I I
guess I misunderstood because I thought
from every other test that that patient
takes for the rest of their
life is going to not be the simple the
the regular thing the the free one the
free one was talking talking and walking
or walking and talking but the once
you've been diagnosed you're no longer a
walker talker you're now going to have
to pay
annually for the yes the
deductible not get it free like you
would if you were still in the
walkie-talkie so that means we're not
just giving the
,000 the first time they were taking
that every time that woman goes in and
gets another
test every time she gets a diagnosis
test she is going to be hit with ,000
and what we're about to do is give her a
lifetime
waiver from that
deductible you're only
given no no okay well let's we'll figure
this out we'll figure this out in the
SubCom
okay thank you thank
you
okay it's every diagnostic every
time
if you're going to testify please put
turn in your cards so I know who I have
because I don't want to be thinking that
I'm getting near the end and all of a
sudden cards appear out of
nowhere yes yes
yes what's
that
why the committee there's there's stud
study committee that the commissioner
has I I all I know was somebody put the
bill in wasn't
me okay we'll open the public hearing of
1081 and here from represent
Pro good afternoon Mark and I'm sorry
about the delay good afternoon that's
okay we're all getting overtime
right
nothing good afternoon uh thank you Mr
chairman and the committee uh my name is
Mark PR I'm a representing Hillsboro 15
which is Manchester w 8 uh today uh I'm
introducing hos Bill
1081 uh been a long day um and it's a
simple housekeeping B that just directs
health insurance companies to send the
check for ambulance service to the
ambulance right and not to the patient
because uh what we hear is that a lot of
them are confused why did I get this
check what do I do with this check how
do I do something with this check where
am I sending it to right um so so
they're
inconveniencing the patient who isn't
probably in in the best shape seeing how
they just had to take an ambulance right
and now they're trying to deal with this
when they probably have other things uh
to do uh and I
know I've heard that insurance companies
don't send checks to out of network Pro
providers but I know I've used out of
network doctors and I have never
received a check for the doctor that I
have to send to the doctor it always
just goes right to the
doctor and as far as I can tell and I've
been at this for a little while couple
of years now the ambulance emergency
ambulance
service is the only one that they send
the
check to the
patient not really sure why I kind of M
they're trying to get us to go in
network you know kind of blackmail us
into doing it you know we'll send you
the check if if you jump in our network
but we really don't want to be in the
network so
um that's pretty much my gist on the
bill
uh I think it's a simple fix as you can
see in the uh in the bill itself we're
just crossing out one one line in this
whole thing just cleans it up tells them
to send it to us and and I think that's
just better for everybody involved and
with that I'll take questions okay
representative
Gibbs thank you um and thank you for
coming to testify uh uh I'm going to ask
you if you're aware of two things um the
first is that um at least as far as I
know in conquered New Hampshire there
are no in network and uh ambulance
providers that are in network with
Anthem uh so Anthem always sends the
check to the
patient and uh are you aware of the
incredible remarkable hassle it is for
the patient to then deal with that check
and figure out what to do with it and I
speak here from personal experience um
with an insurance company that said oh
well they're out of network um and there
are no in network ambulance providers
and I said to the this person uh from
the insurance company I said if you woke
up at 3:00 in the morning in
excruciating pain you would do exactly
what I did and that is call 911 and get
into whatever ambulance they sent um and
she said yes that's true but she still
send the check to me um and I guess I'm
saying are you aware of these things I
am and that's why I'm bringing this bill
forth right because we have those
patients that I work for eping fire
perfect
disclusion um and we have those people
call us all the time hey I got this
check it has your name on it I don't
know what to do with it where do I where
do I send this and we have to give them
the address they have to stick in an
envelope and send it to us when they
have other things to worry about so yes
I'm well
aware well
when I I'm pretty sure you send a letter
after you've done the you send a letter
to the patient and tell them that when
they do get that check ahead of time
because I I certainly know that Peter
bro does that I don't believe we do okay
because I know Peter bro does yeah okay
repres I was wondering if you could
answer a question I know that there's a
I guess it's a study committee that was
formed by is formed by um commissioner
beton court and who said that this is
not a legislative issue so I'm wondering
how this ties in with I believe Senators
here who is on that committee how this
ties in with what the commissioner's
doing so unfortunately I wasn't able to
make it to that Commission because I
would have tried to have dealt with it
then I found about found out about the
commission too late apparently but I I
believe this is a legislative issue okay
just to follow up he said it was not so
I'm
confused I'm confused now
too good so the issue of the commission
was the reimbursement dollar
amount the issue that that Mark bringing
in is sort of been a side issue it to
the overall it it certainly would be
because it would be an overall Final
Solution what representative BR he's
bringing this in because the ambulance
issue has never been solved it can
seemingly can't solve and he was just
saying at least can you at least just
send us that check and and uh at at as
as a in the meantime before the ultimate
solution is
solved representative
speaker it seems very straightforward uh
but who determines the size of the check
I mean is it just whatever is covered in
whatever the person's insurance policy
is regardless of what the ambulance
ended up spending to do it boy that's a
whole another road to go down so they're
going to send us an amount and whatever
they
decide exactly and I'm not really sure
how they decide that but they do okay
and it's not it's usually nowhere near
what we've requested what we've built I
know when the oil company comes and
drops oil in my tank they send me a bill
for $1,000 and and I know if I said hey
I only want to pay
300 the next person knocking on my door
would probably be a police officer so
that's a whole another story okay that's
separate from this I just want to get
the check because like the
representative said she got this check
and she had no idea what she supposed to
do with it and unfortunately that
happens quite a bit I also would just
throw in a curveball here there is two
different kinds of checks that actually
come up yeah and that is um you whether
the claim was made under the med
pay and of their auto insurance and that
will uh theoretically could be a higher
dollar amount and that would go to
directly to the again to the the person
who had the insurance but that dollar
amount would be whatever usually what
the uh the the ambulance build it build
for as long as it stays under what the
total med pay was so what just so we
everybody know in a discussion we're not
talking about that issue not we're
talking
about insurance health insurance and
health insurance meaning that you
weren't in your car you had your heart
attack or whatever inside your home your
health insurance is picking it up and
the insurance companies says we don't
have a contract we don't have anything
with this ambulance company and uh and
notwithstanding that that they don't
have a dollar amount in what they have
so they have what they believe is the
the appropriate fee and that is what the
insurance commissioner is trying to
negotiate and work out out a solution in
terms of how that dollar amount is
addressed and how is it really truly the
appropriate dollar but it's still
outside of the the fundamental issue
which he described everybody which is
it's because they don't have an
agreement with the insurance company in
that case if they did if they were as a
as a provider that check would go
directly to them but they don't have
that contract at even a lesser amount of
money and and of course it's what they
decide that they think is the
appropriate amount okay you've already
had a question so
now so what what we're talking about
here because we've we've been dealing
with these this ambulance stuff for the
last several years all we're dealing
with here is that as I understand this
bill is that in this situation where the
insurer has a contract with a provider
the money goes to the provider if the
provider is out of
network the insurance company has the
practice of paying whatever they're
going to pay to the insured and not to
the ambulance company and what this bill
is directed to do is to have the
insurance company send the money to the
outof network provider whatever it is
that they have decided to pay rather
than to the
insured so that in effect out of network
work and network will be treated the
same that's that that is my
understanding that's that and then we
can if everybody understands that and
and and they're okay with that we can go
home thank you very much Mr
chairman has a question thank you I
think I might have a good one here um
what you believe uh in
2018 there was a study uh committee
study commission that issued a report on
the subject it was chaired by by Lori
sandborn uh one of the findings
is reimbursement checks issued to both
the insured and the provider lead to a
number of problems it is confusing and
inconvenient for the consumer makes it
difficult for the provider to get
payment Anthem does not issue checks to
two payes and the first recommendation
of the report is delete the phrase or
buy a check payable to the insured and
the ambulance service provider from the
first sentence of so the first
recommendation of this report is your
bill so would you you believe yes yes I
would and I'm surprised I have to be
here
again okay representative Gibbs has
thank you uh this is another would you
believe I'm afraid would you believe
that for conquered patients dealing with
Anthem nobody sends a letter to the
patient right about how the money is
going to be paid the check just re just
appears in the mail with no explanation
at all as to why you're getting it or
sometimes even who the ambulance company
was that you're supposed to send it to
so you have no idea what to do with it
correct which is troublesome for
patients who are having issues already
you know because they needed an
ambulance and now they have to deal with
this which we don't think is fair on a
number of
reasons and we all set thank you very
much for your testimony you're welcome
uh chair will call on Heidi
croll is this it for health insurance
mandate day or do I have another
one no we have another we have another
Insurance day don't we yeah I think we
do have yeah
okay good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee again for the record my
name is Heidi croll I work at Gallagher
Callahan and gartell and I'm here today
on behalf of ahip which is America's
health insurance plans
um this bill is one that you've seen um
many times before
um I've participated in the uh uh
stakeholder processes and study
committees along the way um including
the one that was um convened by the
insurance department uh at the end of
last session and numerous stakeholder um
meetings were held um and I think you
know we're kind of at the point where we
tried to come to resolution um and I
think at this point without success uh
on on that on that effort um not for
lack of um trying I think people you
know uh learned a lot of information
shared uh their thoughts and opinions
and I I think people learned a lot but
we didn't come to a resolution
um as you've heard I mean again
obviously this is a policy decision but
um when the ambulance providers are out
of network sending the check to the
patient is the only leverage that the
carrier has to try to get the carrier to
to try to get the provider to come into
Network
um and the tug and pull here is is that
um when a provider an ambulance provider
is out of network um they are allowed to
balance bill um and so anything you know
they have their full charge and whatever
is not covered by the insurance um
company is balance Bill to the patient
um there was mention of uh for an outof
Network doctors um that they do get a
check directly that's negotiated um
between the outof network doctor and the
carrier and the difference is that under
the no surprises act the doctors are not
allowed to balance bill um so that is a
I think an important distinction um and
of course balance billing is um you know
harmful to to client to to patients um
and we've had a balance you know we've
got our own New Hampshire statute on the
book for a while around balance billing
no balance billing um but ambulance
providers you know have not been part of
that
um so I think you know I would just
leave it at that it's it's really and
the final thing I guess I would say is
that when the check does go to the
patient um in part it's that's the only
contractual relationship that the
carrier has it's the contractual
relationship with the patient um and not
with in this case not with the ambulance
provider so
um I'll leave it at that happy to answer
any questions but I know it's late in
the day and there are other people who
would like to speak as
well okay so does everybody understand
that the difference between you and a uh
the anesthesiologist who didn't have is
not in network is that they do pay the
anesthesiologist directly because the
anesthesiologist promises not to balance
bill
so so if you're willing to promise not
to balance bill then they'll send you a
check promise toay what we
s right but that's the same issue with
the NZ cist the enologist sends out a
big fat Bill and they say we're not
going to pay that big fat Bill we're
going to pay a lower
one that's correct your service is
totally different that is correct did
you do something that nobody else is
which is that we got to pay for you to
be Stand By and that's the
problem
that's that no doubt that is the the
heart of the problem is that that we're
paying for you to be there not not be
you know to be on
call and I'm sure you I've never heard
anybody complain about any that's true
except we did have problem in Kean for a
while okay yeah thank you for taking my
question how difficult would it be to
send that same check the same amount
that you send to the patient to the
person or the or the the ambulance uh
company that provides the service
service why how is that so difficult to
do or why I don't think it's an issue of
being it's difficult that we know we
know that the ambulance is going to send
a bill they're out of network they're
going to send a bill to the patient and
the carrier has given the patient
because that's who the contractual
Arrangement is with the carer has given
the patient the reimbursement that they
would you know standard reimbursement
for the service the part with what they
would have given if the
fire accepted so the idea is that the
bill is
$1,000 and and the insurance company's
paying 750 instead of paying the 750 to
the ambulance directly they sending the
750 to the patient because they know the
patient has got to write that thousand
check to the
ambulance the the the the provider would
be paid directly if they are in network
and I know that you know there are
ambulance providers who are in network
um but not not of them certainly not
municipal fire departments just a just
to follow up could could you um send a a
notice with the check to the patient
that they need to send this check to the
ambulance
service I can check with I I can check
with the carriers I don't know what
their Protocols are um but no that's
that's a fair point
yep
y That's excuse me isn't it typical when
a health insurance company makes a
payment that they uh that that they
describe what they're paying
for you know you get you get a check
stub or an EOB right typically with
insurance and says this is what we're
paying for so so you you don't I I've
never had this happen so when you send
out a check to to a policy
holder for an ambulance service that's
been provided by an out of network
provider you don't include an EOB
explaining what the check is you just
send a check that says made out to John
Smith for
$424 and the person and and John Smith
has no idea why you got a check for $4
$24 I'm just trying to understand this
I've never had this occur in my life
before I would have to check with the
carriers you know ahip is an association
so I don't know individual we have to
ask Insurance comp we do have Anthem so
you can ask Anthem that
question yes no yes yeah would you
believe that if you had mortgage or rent
payment due and you had no money what
are you going to do with the check I
mean and I'm not I'm not condemning it I
mean if you you have a choice between
paying your rent and not and you get get
this check you're going to use it well
that's a related issue but it's not the
same it's not the same question
representative
Gibbs thank you and I I'm going to
apologize Upfront for the way I'm going
to put this because I just don't know
how else to put it and I speak here from
personal experience where I've been
driven crazy several times and you said
that the reason that the in insurance
companies send the check to the patient
is because that's the only way they
leverage over the ambulance companies to
try to get the ambulance companies to
come in in network
so it's okay with the insurance company
it's okay with you that you drive the
that the insurance companies Drive the
patient crazy in order for the insurance
companies to get leverage over the
ambulance companies which the patient
has absolutely no control over
whatsoever
question so I I I don't think the
insurance companies are trying to
intentionally Drive their their members
crazy I don't they don't think member um
customer service is important to them so
um we know how those mental mental
health benefits I would how high they
pay I would say if there are ways to
improve the co uh communication and the
correspondence um between the carrier
and the patient um when that check
arrives um I'm not familiar with what
that looks like but if there's a way to
improve that communication so that it is
clear um I think we'd be open to you
know talking about that thank you very
much okay Michael
satar representing the New Hampshire
Association of Fire
Chiefs and obvious support of this
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee I won't I have a whole long
letter here but I won't won't read it
because I know the day is late and
um things but but I what what I do want
to say is my name is Michael sear I'm
the fire chief of the Tilton Northfield
fire district so I'm the chief of Tilton
and Northfield and I'm representing the
New Hampshire Association of Fire Chiefs
and supported this bill um I'll cut
right to the chase on this my currently
my department is not in network with any
insurance carriers over the past year my
department received 164 claims directly
paid from carriers with which our
department is not in
network at the same time we have had to
attempt to recover 29 claims totaling $
43,2
something5 are averaging
$1,492 each from individuals who have
received checks directly from the
carriers ambulance providers do not need
to be in network to receive payments it
happens in our department routin rely so
we do receive checks from directly from
pay uh carriers all the
time there are many times where we just
don't and then the bill goes I mean the
check goes to the patient and then they
end up getting a bill from
us and if they can't resolve that issue
they end up going through a process and
you know we have uh checks and balances
in place if they're if they're a
hardship case they can apply for a
hardship and we'll wave the bill many
times that's what happens but so we do
have a process and we don't take people
to send people the collections every
time that something like this happens so
uh we're very sensitive to that so I
would suggest that just changing the
language in this bill would solve the
problem and make everything easier for
everybody because uh even in my own
department where my own members who have
insurance have used an ambulance in
their own Community where they live and
they have to go through this issue where
they're calling their insurance company
say Hey you sent me the check and now
I'm getting a bill from the town that I
live in that I ow that money why didn't
you send it to them and it's a process
but then when I deal with residents
within my own Community especially um
elderly people who are really not aware
of how the whole system works it's very
confusing for them trying to get a hold
of the insurance company on the phone is
practically damn near impossible I'm
sure you've all tried to do it and you
get on hold and you're there forever so
it's very frustrating for the customer
it's frustrating for the fire
departments that are providing the
service just trying to recover some of
the costs incurred providing the service
because what we don't recover ends up
going on the tax rate because we're
still going to provide the service that
the residents of the community uh expect
so um I think that's enough for now I
Happ to answer any questions
representative Terry so I we just want
to be clear here with respect to uh your
billing of the the the person for whom
you provided the service this person in
this instance in which I'm citing
receives a
check from the insurance carrier for X
number of dollars you're out out of
network provider so that's why you
didn't get anything you bill for the
total amount of your service to the
person who you provided the service for
who received a check from his or her
insurer and there are instances in which
you get nothing from the the person for
whom you uh provided the service or
you're only getting an amount that's
equal to the amount of the check was
provided how can you can you can you
break that down for us because I can I
can foresee a situation where somebody
gets a check and then they just decide
they're just not going to pay anything
now is that is that are you describing
situations like that to us yes we have
situations like that um unfortunately we
have some um people within my community
that call for the ambulance on a regular
basis and they have insurance they get a
check and they don't send the check to
the fire department they actually use
that as part of their income in my opin
that's my opinion that's what it seems
like
you're
welcome thank you very much for your
testimony thank you I have one more card
left
Sabrina you get the last word oh I I'm
sorry I do have another card sorry oh
Chris there you are I was wondering you
were here and why would you not speak
okay
two hello chairman hunt and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify my name is
Sabrina Dunlap I'm director of
government relations for Anthem I know
it is very late and as uh chairman hunt
knows I I can talk a lot about ambulance
we have been talking about this for a
long time years but in fact since about
last year when you all had a bill in
front of you very similar to this we did
have I had my own meetings um with
ambulance providers and then the
insurance department organized meetings
and I will say you know I think everyone
was at the table in good faith these
issues are complicated in part because
you're talking about some private
ambulance providers and then a whole lot
of municipalities I'm involved in my
little Town's local government so I
totally understand the complexities that
go into ambulance and running it and it
gets complicated when you know my town
has decided that we're going to pay for
247 ambulance and that costs a lot of
money and the town does get money from
insurance companies but part of it does
fall to the taxpayers so it's like a
whole another ball of wax that's
involved with this issue that we don't
have with other parts of healthcare
um I will also just say that you know
the focus has been on Commercial
Insurance but a very significant number
of of people in the realm of ambulance
are have Medicare and Medicaid um so I
don't think the focus on commercial
insurance is going to like solve the
problem um so I'm I'm happy to talk
offline more about this I just want to
make a few other points Anthem does have
a significant number of ambulance
providers in network both private
companies and municipalities um um and I
think the key difference that's been
mentioned is balance billing so what
happens if a provider is out of network
we have no contractual relationship with
them none whatsoever and so they send
I'm just going to use big numbers
because keep the math easy they send us
a bill for $10,000 they're out of
network we say the allowed amount is
$5,000 we pay them the allowed amount in
many cases the member then gets the
balance bill of
$5,000 that's because ground ambulance
was excluded from the no surprises act
which prohibits balance billing so so
that is the key issue um and you know it
is it does seem sort of silly I I can
understand you know this notion of like
why send the check to the member but the
fact is we have a contractual
relationship with the member we don't
with out of network providers and the
goal is to get them in network and I I
think you know we are we continue to
have these conversations we're coming to
the table in good faith there was a
comment about not knowing why insurance
companies pay what we pay well during
those many meetings with the insurance
department it wasn't totally clear to
many of us how the ambulance companies
come up with what they what they charge
so um I think these are complicated
issues again happy to take questions
happy to talk more about this um but I
will say I think everyone has come to
the table in good faith I don't think
this bill striking that language solves
a problem thank you very
much representative AMT thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking our question
questions just so I understand uh what's
the process involved in getting an
ambulance provider to come into Network
why is that such a why why might they be
resistant to that thank you for the
question so my understanding is first of
all I think it's made more complicated
because we have so many towns that have
their own little ambulance company or
you know they run their own ambulance
and so you're talking about
municipalities and private companies um
the process is the same that we use with
other providers where you know there's
Outreach made you come to the table and
you negotiate in good faith and I'd say
both sides have to give a little on that
and I'm not on the Contracting team so I
don't know all the details but generally
it's you know two parties coming to the
table to negotiate what they think is a
fair price and then once the providers
in network they know what they're going
to be
paid yeah well given that I know have a
County uh Ambulance Service in which I'm
sit on the fight finance committee and
um my take uh where what the problem is
and it was a little bit of what we
talked about just before which is that
when it comes to health care services
that that it's by appointment and
they'll take you when they're going to
take you and the problem is is that our
ambulance services are
247 and so now we have a cost analysis
problem to you know you want to have
that ambulance available all the time
but the reality is they can't Bill like
we normally do in terms of healthcare or
on a per hourly per
service case and that's the discrepancy
and if I could that reminds me of one
other thing one other issue that came up
during those meetings was this issue of
treat no transport and there were
comments made that carriers don't cover
treat no transport which is where the
ambulance shows up they don't transport
the patient what we discovered was at
least Anthem we do have codes for treat
no transport but they were very rarely
used and so this was part of the
discussion it's it's like the nature of
ambulance makes it difficult in many
cases to get someone's insurance info
and you know build that and get paid for
that service so that's an issue where
like I don't know what the answer is we
cover it there's a code for it so I
think there's probably an education
piece on that but there's also just you
know it's just Complicated by
Nature great thank you thank you very
much thank you all right
Chris
good afternoon it's very rare that I get
the last word and since I'm going home
this is gonna be great I won't get it
there um so thanks for the opportunity
just you in the
road uh my name is Chris Dew was I'm
from Hollis New Hampshire I just be
brief um I am employed by American
Medical Response AMR ambulance I also
represent the New Hampshire Ambulance
Association we support representative PR
bill bill um I will point out um and
I've been here before and testified on
the same uh or similar bills I will
point out that the leverage that we're
trying to get here or have been trying
to get for the last 10 plus years is not
working so I think we need to do
something else and this would be a great
first step for uh fairness and an
opportunity for the insurance carriers
to come to the table and get the
attention of the ambulance providers by
doing this and getting these folks to
try to come into Network I think would
it would be great
second to that um and chairman you
reference it um the ambulance providers
ground were left out of the no surprises
act for a very specific reason and it's
because of the cost for Readiness the um
federal government put together a ground
ambulance patient billing committee
Which senate Apprentice was on they'
have come up with their recommendations
which are being finalized and they're
going to be voted on and sent to
Congress so that Congress can include
ground ambulance es in the no surprises
act so within a very short period of
time
legislatively that piece will be solved
um in the meantime I think it's prudent
given the way that um healthc care and
the economy is being driven that we take
the patient out of the middle and get
the ambulance providers the dollars that
they need so that they can do the
services that everyone needs and and
wants to be provided with thank
you great any questions see
none
okay what I got here
uh Heather stal is in support of the
bill Katherine heck is in support of the
bill Chris we heard Sabrina and through
Apprentice is also in support of the
bill and with that I will close the
public
hearing